[Music]
shalom everybody shalom shalom
uh welcome to frenemies today we are
doing
jewish trivia because trisha stepping to
me
of all people the king of the jews aka
and um you really think you can beat me
at jewish trivia uh
yes
you gotta hit that i don't know if baaru
has that yeah i don't think it does
it does not have no
[Music]
today of course as a haseed remember
when i called you a histic jew before i
met you on the
on your podcast i said they're hasidic
jews yeah when i put this outfit on you
said to me
that's how i imagined you before i met
you and i was like what the first video
you did about me where you like
were hateful on my appearance or that i
was photoshopping was
my initial reaction was like oh this is
a hasidic jew like pissed at me but i
was dressed normally
but your internal was hasidic you think
i was i was conveying a conservative
view on the world or something yeah well
just in my experience acetic jews like
actually do like spit on you in fairfax
oh for real for real oh well don't go on
fairfax
i used to live by uh good at you i only
throw hands with those [ __ ] it
happened twice and one time his daughter
was taking pictures there's like a
jewish school
uh right there by erwan because i just
live by the palazzo and it's right there
so i just go walk to get my nails done
there
and one of the a couple of the girls
were getting pictures of me well my
shirt said like pornhub or
which i had no idea and the dad came and
literally like what he like grabbed her
like he like spit on me like
like what are you doing with this trap
like that like that's all i know if i
see the jews yeah they're the worst i
mean with peace and love of course
and they're the worst well and women are
not allowed to like pray but
non-orthodox jewish women can pray and
they can wear the tally
yeah so a little bit of a story when
growing up because my
lib ass uh and reformed my ass is so
reformed we had a
female rabbi which i thought was normal
but when i went to israel apparently me
and eli tried to get married in israel
and every all a marriage is run through
the state it's not like here where
you can't go off and get like elope you
know what i mean like it has to go
through the state
it has to go through the rabbit night
and all this [ __ ] it's like a very
religious
doctrine yeah and so i was like
i have to prove to them that i'm jewish
to get married to evo
i thought that was your birthright
that's how you did a birthright trip
because you're
yeah but like but like apparently they
take the marriage thing more seriously
oh my god how'd you
approve it so i had so i got a letter
from my rabbi stating that i'm a bar
mitzvah and that i'm jewish and that my
family lineage
goes all the way back and they're like
you are they're like do you think i'm
[ __ ] stupid
i can't accept this [ __ ] from your
female rabbi we don't acknowledge her
i was like holy [ __ ] i was like wow okay
so my dad had to go to some synagogue in
las vegas where they lived at the time
and bribe some bribe
which i love that this is somehow more
official he gave
a donation to the synagogue so that they
would write me a letter saying i was
jewish
oh my god he was like the original roy
laughlin
right like oh because i'm painting well
let's get into the jewish world my
credentials are real
that's what i mean that's true they said
they said that were they then get a
female rabbi is that a real thing or was
that just like a forward thing
i i don't know i mean in america well
they're recognizing it's super reformed
no not by the rabbidite in israel
so it's not real so you're bar mitzvah
maybe no but my lineage as a jew is real
right because you did a dna test right
you're i'm like yeah exactly
i'm so excited i hope i win so i can say
i beat a jew like
one against can you be a jew well my
genetic makeup doesn't necessarily
indicate how well i'm gonna do a trivia
you know you should though if you like
grew up that way and you went to hebrew
school
i agree you would think that i would
perform better than you but i'll say
just based on what i know about you and
our time together is that
you i've i expect you to win for some
reason i mean i hope so i've been
that there again you literally didn't
even know about the holocaust existed
like a month ago holocaust aside i do
know jewish history very well
because i was like a poser most of my
life how can you not know about the
holocaust know about jewish trivia
because every jewish guy i've dated
never brought that up they brought up
rosh hashanah so i had to like learn
what that is you know
like all these things and now with my
israeli fiance i have to learn about
okay well we'll put you to the test
today that's for sure so i hope we i
hope we have a lot of like israeli like
jewish hebrew
maybe not so much holocaust although
holocaust
there better be a question about the
holocaust that's very important if you
want to come here and act like you're a
jew of my pedigree
anne frank is on the cover of time
magazine this month
so shout out to her delayed why is she
on the time why i don't know
she didn't even die in the holocaust i
looked that up did you know that she
like
kind of started she didn't what she died
in a concentration camp no no no
no i think that's false i'm pretty sure
her younger siblings died in the
concentration camp and she went on to
like work and stuff like that girl you
are so wrong i don't think so because i
looked up and i was like what's her
tragedy
anne frank died in 1945 in bergen-belsen
concentration camp in germany
oh i already lost yeah but i do love
what are you coming out here with this
[ __ ] and frank trivia like what are
you even talking about
i swear i looked that up i said you
didn't look [ __ ] up i said it yesterday
to moses and he didn't disagree with me
he's like oh that makes sense
well i don't think moses necessarily
knows much either to be frank to be
honest
oh my god he is an oh jew also
do i kind of like the virgin mary in
this i kind of like it i feel like a
cosplay
by the way according to conservatives
you sh it's a sacrilege for you to wear
that
not orthodox women can wear it
virgin mary was jewish so technically
that is nice
blasphemous you know if mary no she
wasn't
wait oh yeah she was you're right and
also did you know it's basically
crushing them they paint the virgin mary
as caucasian but she would actually be
more like
middle eastern looking mm-hmm yes i do
know that
jesus was not a blind yeah in case
you're wondering jesus was not a
blond-haired blue-dyed
uh aryan master race he's literally a
middle eastern [ __ ] jew from like two
thousand years ago that dude was like
crusty ass like peasant he was a crusty
ass peasant bro
you know what i mean like go to go to
israel and you'll see what he looked
like who was friends with the [ __ ]
so for anyone who's like trisha you do
only fans and love jesus like
he was friends with jesus like horns and
stuff yeah jesus was a shady dude
is what we're trying to say no he was
shooting dice and everything bro
i'm a jew for jesus just fyi like i do
believe in jewish culture and judaism
but i'm also a jew for jesus
so jews do not just for the record jew
for jesus is like
a real a huge sacrilege it's in israel
there's jews for jesus yeah they're
considered freaks are they getting
stoned no so i think it's okay in israel
no
because in israel we don't stone people
for their religious beliefs
people don't get stoned in israel for
they don't you know what i mean yeah for
sure that's kind of something that
happens elsewhere
um like uh like uh like uh alabama
no i'm kidding i see we have are you
eating these today there's buns with our
hebrew
okay so here before we begin the jewish
trivia
i was given this gift by
unnecessary inventions on
um i don't know this is the glizzy
gripper now you say you've never tried a
hot dog right
in fact if anyone can find me eating a
hot dog i'll give you a thousand dollars
because i really don't think i've ever
the search begins someone's already
located it
so let me show you because eating a hot
dog can be very compromising for example
watch this
oh that doesn't look that bad because
the wiener wasn't facing the camera you
should have the winner facing the camera
like this so yeah
but don't oh
it's a lot of bread they're big dogs so
are you officially off keto
okay love it's better honestly it's can
i tell you i lost two pounds this week
and i've been like stuffing my face
why i got an elliptical machine and i do
it every night for like two hours and i
did it for three days and i lost two
pounds
so um yeah two hours every day and i
watch yeah i watch podcasts while i do
it it's great we have this whole new
watching my podcast or you watch
impulsive i did watch your podcast
you did you what yeah i didn't watch
impulsive it's kind of been going down
lately but i
i watched your podcast oh really prove
it wait what is happening here okay so
because it's real i can prove it
because it's so embarrassing to be
eating a hot dog in public
the glizzy gripper makes it so that you
can eat your hot dog in peace and
serenity
watch
wow also wait wait a second you said
these are kosher but jewish people can't
eat pork
it's cow it's beef all beef so it's fake
hot dog
who's this why are you keeping hot dogs
because we're in
our jewish gear today like i feel like
we should honor our traditions
okay we'll take one without and let's
see how compromising it is
oh yeah that's compromising that is
a lot you usually have to pay for that
stop
how dare you these are these are
i can't you can spit it out okay
if it's really that bad someone get her
a bucket or something oh
i'm gonna cry church i've seen you eat
some horrid [ __ ] and you're gonna piss
me off oh my god
why does it taste like bologna right it
does kind of taste like baloney
um oh my god i just hate the like smell
of hot dogs like
even in those korean fried cheese things
i get if there's a wiener in there i
like cannot eat it like it's like i can
smell it through the thing
well i think where the scent try the try
to bite it
just so you can know where to hide this
yeah you can just get rid of that
get rid of it where just on the plate
whatever okay so now try it out because
the first time i was are we being
sponsored by grizzly gear today
glizzy gripper this looks even worse
this looks like i'm trying to blow
somebody in private go ahead
take a bite from the glizzy clip gripper
you see that it's so secretive it looks
like
a sucking dick how dare you say that
is this your invention no unnecessary
inventions on tick tock made this and
sent me the original glizzy
gripper i like that we're a mukbang
channel now we're a mukbang podcast
well i'm gonna take one more bite
because i love these dogs and i'm not
gonna get a chance to eat another one
since
either will not allow it you're skinnier
i think you look skinnier to this week
actually i do think okay
i don't know how
this angle is
well good job for being kosher
am i invited to pass over this year
really
my mom wanted to invite you for dinner
oh no but
we're all like let me see if she really
wants to do that
your mom no my mom i wanted to see if
you guys really wanted to do that
yeah she did text moses that but i
didn't know if she was just being polite
or like you know people are like let's
do dinner and then you're like i don't
know if you're actually
we really want to but we're like it's
fine um whatever let's talk about it
later
we have plenty to get to today are we
gonna have your you should have your mom
on the podcast for mother's day
i've had my parents on the podcast how
to do did it perform well yeah people
were interested
okay well i have a startup david on
today too shout out to david
shout out to david who's david
go ahead who's david who's david jewish
expert
david and goliath actually wrong yeah is
it not david and goliath
thank you what i thought it was king
david nope
same guy oh it's the same guy wow that
guy has a quite a reputation
he defeated a giant and oh i didn't know
that what a legend
he does deserve a star know who
let's not confuse king david with david
dobrik though that is not
cause can you take these glizzies out of
here because i won't want to stop eating
why why do you say call them glizzies
yeah are we is this a david dobrik free
episode this week no we can talk about
it it's just
the thing about david dobrik obviously
excuse me let me just finish
the thing about david dobrik is he sucks
you look great as a his seed yeah i do
kind of look good as a history
you know h m got in trouble for selling
scarves that looked like this not that
long ago so maybe i will get in trouble
actually i don't know by the way you
guys noticed the
bleached curlies to commemorate my
bleached hair
by the way i just wanted to point out
that my hair you look cry
i have the exact same hair as this
character from the fifth element i just
want to point it out before we move on
thank you thank you you remember this
guy from the fifth element
oh my god you do look like literally his
hair whoa
and he was a sex icon in that movie so
wait really
yeah look i've actually never seen the
fifth element i just know cosplay like i
know
you guys should dress up as them you
kind of are already no but like with the
full outfits and everything
which one is that is that the one with
orange hair or someone else well you
should just watch the movie
i'm down i'll do it okay we could all be
that
so obviously first of all i want to
congratulate you on your vulture feature
that was pretty cool
i'm in the print copy this week we
couldn't we're trying to get a copy
before we came but we couldn't find new
york magazine but i'm in the print copy
this week of new york magazine so if
someone let me know where to find it
apparently it's just so popular everyone
bought it out already
no i don't think it didn't even have it
at our location but i was so excited
because like you know a lot of people
like
you know deaf noodles d'angelo wallace
they were getting the feature i was like
okay everyone's getting featured on it
but they're like yours is gonna be in
the print and i was like oh you got a
big ass feature they did like photo
shoots yeah they're like coming into my
house and
i don't know you got naked for them was
that odd moses was there the whole time
um no for me it's not it's just funny
because moses was there so i was kind of
like awkward a little bit was it awkward
or what does
you did you were cause you said the
neighbors you you said that
at some point
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's fair no i'm
always naked like effort of everybody
community trisha come on
no but like for music videos or photos i
love being i just like to be i'd rather
be naked in front of people and it gets
weird when people think it's weird like
you would rather be naked than clothes
all the time because i do think i look a
little better naked because
my belly shows through clothes more so
so anyway there was something
that in that article that i found
interesting apparently you've written
seven self-help books is that self-help
i mean sorry sorry it says you've
written 11
self-help books not self-help but books
so this is not an accurate
article are you sure it's self-help i
swear to god this is a direct copy and
paste did it say self-help
i was like girl you i wrote one selfie
you should be reading self-help books
not writing them
that well they got that wrong because
they fact checked with me and i went
through and i said well they said
originally like 13 books but i actually
wrote 11 books only one of them is
self-help it's called curvy and loving
it i wrote it in 2009. you have
authority on that
thank you yeah just like body positivity
so that was like self-help like how do
you
like
how have you written 11 books are you
making money from these books where
are these yeah i get like a couple
hundred a month and i wrote them in like
2009 or something i wrote them before
any youtuber wrote books
i was like the og publishing on shout
out amazon self publishing like
i was like publishing so many books i
have like three life stories i have
history of my insanity
you have three different life stories
are they all yeah there's only 24 when i
wrote them
oh my goodness and then i have a horror
movie book it's called trisha's 31
nights of fright
i have oh i have a i have an erotic
fiction called tease
oh my god i have a lot i don't know i
just like writing i have a poetry book i
have i have a lot of books
you're a prolific uh author i didn't
know that i did not proofread any of it
so i think i have a lot of well shout
out to vulture for saying you've written
11 self-help books well not self-help
books i didn't know they put that there
that's kind of crazy have you read your
own article
be honest um
no yeah because it kind of seemed mean
at first i was like wait is she kind of
being like shady towards i read the
whole thing it was nice but it was like
a little shade like she kind of
well yeah because well she was yeah the
tone was like
she should be cancelled but she's
uncancelable but she's irresistible i
mean i
i feel like it was fair but they also
had like two trump mentions and i'm not
sure why that was synonymous with me
like why were they
throwing that in there it was more like
back in the day you supported mitt
romney because he was
whatever it doesn't matter you should i
just don't like the political aspect of
it
i didn't read i just skimmed it but you
know i was cool i like all attention so
i was like thank you
yeah honestly like thank you everybody
for liking me this year this past six
months has been pretty solid
trisha's queen it's gonna change
eventually i'm gonna
yeah yeah yeah of course me too you know
i feel like people like me now too which
is odd
because the past like three years been
nothing but people barely [ __ ] hating
wait really
i feel like that i mean people really
like you but yeah maybe
maybe i just get too focused on the
controversies but there's just been a
lot of them
and it's just been so [ __ ] exhausting
with like
everybody's just angry at me all the
time because i just talk i come on these
podcasts and i talk and i talk and i
talk and then there's
i say this and they don't like that so
they clip just that and then they get
mad at me and then
i just you know but i'm evolving i feel
like i'm getting better i am evolving
what we have to do
i haven't gotten in trouble in a long
time right dan
so that's pretty good i feel like i'm
evolving i mean we're also just old like
it's embarrassing if we're like
you know doing problematic behavior at
50 you know
well i'm 35 first of all might as well
be 15.
my me i don't think i'm old i'm almost
dead
well that might be true but i die
tomorrow i always talk about that sorry
let's skip that i'll be there okay so
please obviously we have a ton of
updates
we've the thing is about david dobrik
first of all is just that
we've both talked about it individually
yeah so i don't i don't necessarily want
to come out here
and rehash but overall like what did you
think about the scotty
oh my god yeah we didn't talk about that
on this podcast no we haven't talked
about it together
just even this morning literally this
morning i said i'm still so perplexed by
this video like why did he like
literally the dumbest
person and i don't know if he's just
dumb i don't know what it is like it was
so stupid but like bottom line when i
was thinking about it i was thinking
like
this is like i think you might have said
it or one of the other podcasts i was
watching is like
if this is the mentality they're all
thinking right everyone stood behind
this video i know david he like has to
approve videos like he has to make sure
everyone's on board with it so they
approve this
so everyone thinks they're like not in
the wrong like that's what's so crazy
like david clearly is not sorry because
rob's like why don't you just apologize
because he's not sorry which is insane
two they're like they think they're in
the right which is even scarier
like that's so cool well so yeah so um
right i uh and also it's evident by the
fact that david
cut out a piece of his text saying oh
look seth asked for a third time
and sent him a voice memo you can hear
him talking so the fact that david sent
him that clip
is basically proof that not only is this
what david thinks but probably what they
all think
that's crazy and so like i thought he
was trying to brush another wrong
because he knows he like [ __ ] up but
no like he's like they like doubled down
with it and was like
we're we're totally fine it's like
you're not even making those vlogs
anymore why don't you say like i'm a
stupid kid whatever yeah i don't know
why he can't apologize no because he's
not not sorry i literally don't think he
thinks he has anything to say sorry for
i think he literally thinks he's
totally cool everything's in the right
and then the rental lawsuit what are
they gonna sue seth for you're the one
who did this to him what are you doing
except for
yeah he threatened to sue me and seth by
the way which what for what for
defamation
well they the scottie clearly doesn't
know what he's talking about because
he's like
you're the reason for this whole thing
snowballing and i was like [ __ ] how
about the fact that david didn't [ __ ]
address this for like
two years how about that bigger it
should be yeah a snowball a snowball is
like a rumor this should be like
this literally should be news because
this is so ins this is so it is going to
be news
i've talked to like why we won't say but
like i've talked to so many people that
like have come forward and like they had
me like validate some people's like
experiences or whatever like that but or
like verify it
and like so many people are coming for
it like it's not just like one two three
people that are
oh and when he called seth bitter
because his career popped up
corny literally punch him in the face
because i was like first of all scotty
neither did your career nobody
literally knows who you are anymore no
one even knew we were in the vlogs and
he's trying so hard and then when he's
like
sorry that you're just like bitter about
this what yeah it was so it's
and the thing about scotty again i'm not
super familiar with the dynamics i would
say my name i wish he would say my name
in that because there's so much [ __ ] i
was like oh i just wish he would see
he said my name he said my name and we
went to war if you check his wiki feed
score
damn why don't you pull that up oh my
god he's got a [ __ ] one dude
he's out of one he got so demolished by
the foot soldiers he's basically
underground he's six feet deep at this
point i think you're a cult leader with
this foot thing that you
got going on yeah okay so you have no
problems with cults and now you don't
have a problem with cults not mine
i don't mind i'm not in that cult you're
a foot soldier stop
no i'm not check your foot rating and
then talk to me about colts
probably really high i don't like the
foot thing that you're talking about
he has one dude he started this whole
this whole apology tour or well defense
store
at 4.8 on wikifee are you pulling it up
dan
oh well i'm just gonna edit it and so he
started at 4.8 he's now down to
one trisha do you understand the power
that i yield as the foot general
i hate this one thing i can't even like
bro it's so funny
with this it's wikipedia it's wikipedia
okay girl well good thing i don't make
my podcast for an audience of just you
but now we're here together so maybe we
should go past foot thing because it
triggers me
why it just does i can't explain okay
okay he's a one though it's pretty funny
it's pretty epic
you look like goldilocks and the three
bears had a baby so anyway yeah i mean
the thing about say that again i think i
missed something
nothing say it again in a good way in a
good way wait i didn't hear you like if
goldilocks and the three bears had a
baby that's what you look like oh like
beastiality the product of bestiality
it's okay and like fables bestiality is
never okay trisha how dare you and fairy
tales
you you're like unless she's shane
apparently because you overlooked the
fact that he just done a scat for like
three years
oh did you see oh did you see rylan's
cousin confirmed that
on tick tock no wait he has a g he has a
betrayer in his own family yeah and she
goes
she goes everything trisha said is right
like
wait why are people in his own family
betraying him
that's a gozard bro that looks just like
ryland it looks just like he
she looks just like riley yo pull that
up i want to watch
that yeah okay so this is apparently
rylan's cousin now we obviously have
absolutely no confirmation
of that obviously other than the fact
that she looks like him
right i guess what you're saying is like
maybe it's not but it is yeah no
we have to acknowledge that okay okay
unless i see like a photo of them
together you know what i mean
okay we could probably investigate
research it but well yeah click around
her account ian maybe she has got he's
gonna come for us for not doing our
scotty he's gonna sue me for defaming
his friend shane
you've definitely [ __ ] on a cat with
peace and love according to this cousin
why would her kids go okay let's watch
this first why wouldn't it because we're
gonna get a bunch of hate for this
but pretty much every single thing that
trisha paytas has said about both of
them
violin and shane was 100
accurate like she was not lying he
[ __ ] his cat
okay how would this girl know
rylance how would rylan's cousin know
shane [ __ ] this guy i know my cousin
[ __ ] his sister
your cousin [ __ ] his sister yeah and
had a baby
but that's so okay and it looks like the
baby from deliverance
who do you remember no no i remember i
just wrapped my head around what you
just said
it looked just like him um wow um
and that's how you know what that was
that's your wow that's your cousin so
she's not even cousins with shane that's
what i'm saying
shane [ __ ] his cat when he was a kid
how would his cousin know about
shane [ __ ] his cat maybe it's
something they've said like it's out
there like you know what i mean when
something's out there you're like oh
[ __ ] how do we cover i gotta say this is
not the most credible
no she's actually she has other ones
about rylan like and they're
there's more send them along like if
there's a picture with him but let's
focus our hatred we've already
shane is already buried hate them just
don't [ __ ] your cat
like it's not a fable right right
goldilocks and three bear okay well that
didn't happen in the fable just to be
clear
goldilocks did never [ __ ] the bears just
for just to clarify that she slept in
their beds all three of them they
weren't there
bro then when they came back they ate
her ass they didn't eat her ass
didn't they eat her or she ran away i
think they [ __ ] demolished her
i think in the original like grimm
brothers they ate the [ __ ] out of her
they're like [ __ ] the forge we got
dinner now
look at you flexing your english major
saying grimm brothers
okay we'll see who's expressive because
like you sucked at english trivia and
now you're like okay grimm brothers hey
chill
chill daddy
yeah these well did they eat or what
what about
the plot the plot symnosis of goldie
bears they're like the [ __ ] thought the
porch was [ __ ]
lukewarm and she didn't like the beds
and that's the whole story you know the
coen brothers are jewish
yeah cohen duh what does that mean it's
like a jewish
name yeah do you know what it means
cohen i don't think it's a hebrew word
okay it's probably on trivia so let's
not okay what does cohen mean no no if
it's on trip
not on trivia wait are you jewish jan
wait which half of your mom or dad my
dad which is fake
right the mom's got a girl you don't
even have [ __ ] in you more favorite
thank you than me
yeah stop who are you we've got like a
jewish supremacist over here my old
dad's side of the family is jewish so
yes i'm not jewish but mom's got to be
jewish
he said he's not jewish or you you're
screaming f well you're you're like one
day of hebrews training away from
spitting at girls on the street on
fairfax
if it wasn't coveted honestly like i
feel like it would be okay
to spit on people maybe like james
charles because he's a predator and why
is james charles's backpack okay like
normal there yeah okay okay okay so
anyway no repercussions for
anyone crystalia is literally getting
like going to jail again like he's
[ __ ] crazy
that's the point i keep making about um
there's a [ __ ]
how do i born with 2.5 crystallia should
not have come back just like scottie
tried to show me the video crystallia
should not have
okay so here's the video and turned back
i am totally sick of seeing my friends
names
like the liked the good reputation one
big nick said he like i said i liked him
i'm like scott you're like the one that
has no problems he's
confident exactly and so i'm pretty sure
again i'm just i'm just making guesses
here i don't obviously don't know
anything but
it seems to me like this was a
calculated move by the vlog squad to try
to deflect
these accusations so they sent scotty
out
ela made a good point she's like that's
like you sending me out to apologize
every time you get in trouble because
people like you
mock me more than you i was like but
that's just even more sense because
you're like having a relationship
together like he's not in a relationship
jason he's never there when southwest
they never filmed together he never hit
the apartment
like i'm so confused why he spoke on
this like it's
so i'm so perplexed well anyway the
whole
if you haven't seen the video it's
called high on scotty's channel and it's
just total
it's just it's like victim shaming
one-on-one when i first watched this
like
i i'll be honest i was upset i i was
like
kind of charged up because i was like
these [ __ ] guys have the balls after
everything says been through
to come out here and threaten him and
try to humiliate him
and assassinate his character and all
this [ __ ] and pile it on him
it's like this is literal victim shaming
101 and the fact that like
in this day and age people can come out
here and still do like you could have
just said you're [ __ ] sorry and
people would have gained respect for you
and just let you be on your [ __ ] way
but the fact that you come out here with
this whole spiel about how
we're good people we know who we are
he's a piece of [ __ ]
he did this and he did that and and also
ignoring all the [ __ ] points that we
actually made like the fact that the
first one
wasn't consented to that there's a clip
of david and jason talking on views
saying that it was admitting that it was
racially motivated and that he knew he
was going to ruin his his he was going
to get [ __ ] for three to five years
that they knew he was from englewood and
that homosexuality isn't accepted there
which made it so
sorry compton and that homosexuality
isn't accepted there which made it
better in david's eye yeah he totally
glossed over all that he tried to say
like
you're ruining people's lives seth
you're gonna get in trouble for this
like
and also i know you already made this
point too but literally we keep saying
the call thing but like this was like
actually so scary when he's like we know
who we are it's like yeah
you have nothing to do with it no one's
accusing you of anything about being a
nice guy and now we're like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with these people like are
you brainwashed are you stupid are you
like
in debt like i don't know what it is i
think it's just a mega
uh echo chamber where they're all in
like this group chat together they all
spend time together
and it's like this is the this is the
correct response from david
it was so scary though that they like
they i really do think now when i like i
got inside on what they think they
probably think everyone is better i
talked to someone who like
left the group after me or whatever and
she was saying the stuff that they said
about me after i left and stuff
um like crazy like saying that i
i threatened to kill some of them like
they're like i think they're like
delusional or something like they're
[ __ ]
what if there is if there's all these
people leaving who are apparently just
bitter losers don't you think that's at
a certain point right
after more than once that happening
doesn't that speak more to your
organization than the people leaving
you know it's like when the teacher is
teaching all these students and they're
all [ __ ] filling the class it's like
doesn't that speak
more of you as a teacher than the
students who are all failing apparently
about that video like i honestly like
there was like literally no words
because i i watched it like i was
driving home and like
literally there was like no words like i
made my video while my mom's like
sitting next to me in the car because i
was just so
sorry you made it when you're driving i
was like you know she can wait man
charge up i was like no it was like
making me like so i don't think i've
ever been so angry from a video because
he was like saying like
when he said the stuff like david's
amazing and jason's great i'm like he
doesn't have a bad bone in his body
it's like yeah i'm glad he's nice to you
dude
oh my god and then just trying to like
and like oh he would just bring up stuff
anyways it was just i i like i'm still
so bad i'm down to watch it again but i
think people will be angry
yeah i mean it's i guess at this point
but it's so good just go it's called
high which apparently is
[ __ ] annoying too like hi like that's
what you that's where you
title your video hi like i'm sorry [ __ ]
i thought it was more serious than just
hi [ __ ] and he's so smug in the
video and just like everything and i'm
like but you know as the kids would say
in the tic tac like oh he thought he did
something you know on tic tacs where
people think they're gonna get like oh
everyone's gonna be behind me on this
and everyone's just like
no well at first everyone was like yeah
because the david fans don't understand
like
the narrative they put forward it omits
all the [ __ ] evidence and so all the
people all the david fans who are still
defending him
haven't seen this clip of jason and
david talking about how it was racially
motivated that they knew it would ruin
his life for three to five years
like it omits all this [ __ ] and so they
still think of seth as like
a clout chaser who just didn't get all
the clout he wanted
and so left bitterly and now i was
trying to destroy it if anything i feel
like seth was scared because video is
supposed to come on the podcast on
friday your guys's podcast and yeah he's
like no thanks because he just didn't
want more drama or whatever yeah because
well once when someone like that goes
out goes officially and says i hope
and scotty says of david who obviously
he's talking with
right in in cahoots with in this video
he says date
you should face repercussions and i hope
you do legal repercussions i was like
okay scotty
that's so and you know what like if it's
the truth no one can sue you if you say
you're the truth if you say what yeah
that's just like the guy obviously
doesn't understand uh
defamation lawsuits at all because
clearly
it's on video happening how are you
gonna [ __ ] sue a guy for
giving his [ __ ] opinion on something
that happened to him
and he goes he goes ethan didn't do his
research i'm like you [ __ ]
idiot i'm talking to the firsthand
person's account
what more research can i [ __ ] do it's
literally from the horse's mouth as they
say
that the bitter comment really just
because i've been watching that woody
allen thing and that's what they
almost got such a freak he's like oh
she's better because i fell
in love with it i know it's weird woody
allen is such a monster
it sucks i was like i said in my bio
like i was without like i love
you he is a monster those even the phone
calls that he taped he sounds
so crazy and psychotic on um those
documentaries are so depressing so
messed up and just
evidence once again of what people can
get away without
facing repercussions this guy went on to
keep making videos
to keep collaborating with huge
celebrities and huge people in the
industry
after i can't even i honestly can't even
say it he
he did the most unspeakable uh acts on
his kids and on his family
yeah on [ __ ] five-year-old daughter
and like obviously like another daughter
and like that same daughter he tried to
get custody of and i was like
what the hell anyways my whole point of
that is he did the same thing to he said
to the press like oh mia pharaoh's
bitter because like buy that [ __ ]
yeah so when scott said i'm like that is
like the thing and like i
victim shaming 101 101 he hit every
[ __ ] victim-shaming fallacy there
is i can't wait for the day like
honestly i'm like right i can't i'm
actually like actually can't wait for
the day that a vlog squad remember
says my name because it's like a spoken
world like you can't say trisha they cut
it out one time he was on live and
someone asked
joe said my name and that was the only
live he never re-uploaded because it's
in my name so like people are like not
allowed to speak my name so i like wait
for the day that someone says my name
because like honestly i will go all the
way off including scotland
have you already gone all the way off
scott how about you doing drugs and
having sex with
while jason's kids are in your house
they all live together here we go we're
going off
and have zayn todd you guys bring girls
home while jason's kids are right next
to you
bedroom next to each other jason's down
here and tom
and jason's son and daughter are right
here and they're jason's bang
or topping
[Applause]
ah that is crazy multiple houses two
houses they moved to another house
and jason moved with them and with his
kids yeah and they stayed the night all
the time
the first house jason and his kids
shared a room it's awesome it's like
having your kids stay in a frat house
oh it was disgusting like i could hear
todd like banging people upstairs and
their their rooms were right next to
each other
and i was like what like wow you guys
are disgusting and freaks and
well to be honest yeah to be honest
these
these are kids and that's really falls
on jason for being on absolute [ __ ]
feasibility
now though that video scott is like not
it like you are 30 years old you thought
like that was
crazy the amount of like yeah no it was
it's
uh it's well i'm happy to say d'angelo
wallace left the message who's [ __ ]
yeah we're team d'angelo
okay i flipped you because you hated
d'angelo you wouldn't even call in
because he was on the show
right right that's true i didn't know
anything about him once i watched his
shane i'm literally i'm a d'angelo stan
really good like at researching things
yeah really good you should hire him
i think he's okay
done um
but he left a comment he said scotty are
you trying did david ask you to do this
or are you just losing subs for fun
i was like you go off deangelo why is he
so smart
yeah he's pretty awesome honestly like
and then pewdiepie said something which
doesn't really say anything about
anything and the fact that he's
and he's a bro right like i feel like
bros like logan paul defends david and
stuff and like bro
he's a smart guy he's pewdiepie is an
insightful guy he's a you know what i
mean like
he did a video about me with no makeup
right after you did which was like a
little insulting but okay whatever well
we're still friends you know
sometimes you miss the mark and
sometimes i didn't know that that was
your brand like you know
you are oh anyway whatever we've talked
to us a million times but forgive
pewdiepie for that
not forgive pewdiepie but not the other
person that we didn't talk about last
episode which i almost spilled beans on
but i won't oh
i won't bring that up again that part
he's been through enough why did that
get so much drama it was like all over
well because because i went i don't know
if you saw but in the previous episode
without you on after dark i was talking
about it a lot with the crew
and so i think people got charged up
trying to guess who it was and then we
talked
about it and so everybody was just like
who is this person hear from that person
no would you tell me you think i just
have a lot no i would tell you oh you
would
yeah i didn't hear from him i he said he
told me last time we spoke
have a nice life so well that's nice of
him at least have a nice life
he could have said he could have said
have a bad life
right so he wished me a good life i wish
him a good life too
i do too and for the record i really
didn't fat shame him i said he has
angles that was the whole
okay anyway sorry whoa sorry everybody
knows who it is okay but people but
people were thinking i fashioned him i
literally said
i watched the clip back we didn't well
you were kind of a dick to him
but i wasn't i i feel like i was
defending him did you see on the podcast
he called us the two worst humans ever
yes yeah okay i was like bro and that
was before he confronted me so i was
like wow you really
i was like you really didn't think
highly of me for a long time
mr okay
yeah he's it's fine i don't want he's
not jewish i will say people went and
were harassing him which
is [ __ ] up he's catholic he's a good
honestly he's a good guy
we just uh please he's he's one of the
good ones i mean i don't know if you
wouldn't call him a good person
if you put it in the realm of like he's
upset and that's fine he's going through
stuff
if you put in the realm of like james
charles who's out there predatoring on
six-year-old kids like he's a guy he's a
great guy he's not doing that
is that the standard we have though he's
like well he's well no listen we we had
a bout
it's not like he's a [ __ ] like trisha
how many people have you been the worst
human buy
okay fine whatever well if i don't do
angles anymore look at me i look like a
fat [ __ ] on the show every week
uh you're my favorite fat [ __ ] though
thank you
i feel like we can call each other i
guess you can't call him fat i guess you
can't call people you don't know fat
maybe that's the rule of thumb
well he's obviously really insecure
about his weight i get it
and so you hit him in a soft spot but i
felt like i was different
literally but like i was off belly
that's not an insult
i love a belly well anyway i felt like i
was defending him so when i watched that
clip back i was like that's not really
fact-shaming but okay it's all
we're obviously everyone knows who we're
talking about at this point but whatever
who cares leave him alone
best wishes to him and his family oh
yeah
yeah so did we mention he has a family
we don't get more clues
but it's like the cat's out of the bag
okay so anyway um
you know the only place david is getting
feedback because he's filtering it
everywhere else
tick tock youtube everywhere the only
place he's actually getting feedback
is on the app store reviews for his new
for his new uh app dyspo wait what is in
the app store or
yeah why is this just the ad oh i'm
sorry did you see this ad we made
the the uh you saw it here i'm gonna
play it for everyone who didn't see it
yeah david put out this ad for dyspo and
i was kind of shocked by
because he's he's looking at old photos
and like a shoe box you know
it's so weird and crying but the photos
he chose
kind of struck me as odd what do you
guys think seth
is getting kissed by jason i was like
wow that's the stuff you want to
remember
you know well maybe he's showing remorse
finally seth with a gorilla
what and jason like blackface or native
american face i mean what the hell
is this really something to cherish the
memory of david
you know
i mean this just seems inappropriate
uh you crying him bowling big nick i
mean that's just inappropriate i made
the cuts of the last moments of his life
he's like oh let me just
say sorry about this i was like wow i'll
take that apology
that was shocking to me it would just be
okay okay so anyways that was good i
felt like we were on a late night talk
show like i feel like i was conan like
hey
take a look at this you know conan
always had a horrible sketches like that
oh because i just did a sketch was that
a sketch i guess right yeah it's a
little sketch i thought that was way
better though the late nine ones suck
i feel like that was a good one do you
ever used to have that bear and i was
like or that
the the bear the masturbating bear and
the dog the [ __ ] talking i'm like why
she's explaining your fantasy if based
on your conversation today
oh my god i am not shane okay uh did we
verify that that was at
ryland's cousin
so what i was saying is that the only
place that
feedback is getting through is the
reviews on his app funny and ironically
enough because he can't filter the app
reviews this app
out i'm so confused it's out it's not
out like
yeah do you think we'll get that invite
apparently
apparently um there's a lot of people uh
reselling them
on like twitter and stuff so really we
really wanted to we could
i don't yeah oh yeah we don't want to
support but at the same time like
why is it valued at 200 million if it's
not even out how's that that's what i'm
joking about because this whole tech
bubble is just so ridiculous but also
like all his friends i guess like
invested in it right
did you think that was a good point
about how scotty's an investor of course
it's like broke you have a slight uh uh
conflict of interest okay when you're
literally
an investor in his app and you have a
literal
vested interest in maintaining his good
publication right and scott's only
success has ever come from david so he
probably had like one last hundred
thousand dollars and he put it all into
his app hoping david was gonna save him
again and he's
like [ __ ] we're [ __ ] you know and you
know what i'm just glad that people are
talking about it to be honest like and
it
like i it doesn't have to be about me
but some people have like come forward
and stuff like that and i'm just like
glad people are talking about it because
sometimes like
when it comes to trauma and stuff like
that just talking about and getting your
voice heard like helps a lot too like
just like
having it out there whether there's like
justice music
was like why don't you like take it to
court while it's like so expensive to
sue people like it's not like
what are they thinking like it's so much
work and like no they weren't saying sue
him they were saying go to the police i
was like okay idiot a young black man
who's already humiliated from a
sexual assault that basically many
most people already don't go to the
police because it's just such a
complicated thing to deal with
emotionally
and also it takes time to process so he
goes oh set should have just gone to the
police it's like shut the [ __ ] up
i feel like two in the time like you
said this to me over the weekend
something about when david filmed me
like naked and i didn't know or whatever
and i didn't want it in the vlog
and i was just thinking about it because
i was like oh no that's like not a big
deal but then you like start thinking
about it you're like oh yeah like that
actually is like a violation but you
don't think about it well they think
they go oh trish is a sex worker she
doesn't care but it's like i wasn't at
the time oh you weren't even at the time
no i wasn't doing only fans
so he filmed you naked put it in his
video they accusing seth of the same
thing by the way as
as a way of assassinating his character
and like he's done it to you david has
done it to you
not to excuse it but seth didn't film it
or whatever david filmed this and
uploaded and i asked him not to the
reason i asked nacho was not because of
my body was ashamed because
jason's wife our ex-wife would not let
us move in because she she knew i'd put
out nude
photos before so i said don't put that
on because that's just gonna make a
worse case for us to like move in
together and he put it up anyway so
that's why i was so upset
i wasn't like because i stopped doing
anything naked when i stayed jason
because of his kids and his wife was
like
you know all this stuff like that so
that's why i was pissed and he still did
it and it was just like it was [ __ ] up
and anyways but they didn't have that
energy when that happened and it's
it sucks let me let me address it too
because like i haven't like addressed it
yet like it totally sucks like it does
suck like that
again a different conversation but it
does suck at the same time where was
that energy for her when it happened
during the black lives matter movement
last year because the whole point of
that video was to say that she said the
n word in it
that's why seth in my understanding
reposted it he did not know the name
i know the whole story i followed and
everything i can tell i can give the
context and it sucks but hey
and why was that why is this energy
coming up now to defend david and not
this energy to defend aaron when it
happened a year ago like
it was to weaponize it okay so seth
looked bad
so awful one of the main claims against
seth
that the vlog squad has perpetuated is
that seth has shared
uh uh what they call revenge
p word okay now what's now what actually
happened here there's this girl aaron
used to be a member of the vlog squad
her ex boy first of all this this
horrible thing happened to her
um i'm not here to defend seth i just
want to explain to you what happened
because i feel like the truth
is just really not coming up to the
charge that they're
trying to make to assassinate seth's
character so her ex-boyfriend
mr blacksmail blackmails her and says if
you don't pay me i'm going to release
this clip of you naked saying the n word
and she said no i'm not going to pay you
so he put out this clip of her naked
saying the n-word
and um as you can imagine that's really
traumatic
she said the clip was from 10 years ago
that's not who she is today but you know
i
i certainly can empathize with that as
someone who said things that
long ago you know don't you know is
embarrassing so
um so seth was making a video at the
time
about accountability for the vlog squad
because he called what they're doing
formative performative activism because
he's like dude you guys are out there
being all black lives matter
to look good for your image but
meanwhile when i was part of the
vlog squad eyewitnesses firsthand a lot
of racist stuff happening
and so he included the clip of aaron
which by the way he blur he blurred so
much so
that when i watched it i didn't realize
she was naked it was black barred out
from her neck down all the way i
couldn't even tell that she was naked
there was a lot of we should get this
right since you're trying uh
because there was when we talked about
this last week i was getting a bunch of
messages
he originally posted it with just her
blur
okay people got mad at him for doing
that he took that version down that
video is now private
and reposted it with the image
completely cropped so that it's only her
head
okay to take away all context of her
even being okay
so it was the fact that he posted it
once blurred he never posted it on
blurred that never happened not to say
that that's
what people were saying people were
saying he blow posted on blurred
which would be a horrible thing to do
that's not true so so anyway he
like dan said so he put it in his video
about accountability it
appeared for like three seconds it was a
very brief ex uh
very brief um part of his video
and um listen i don't think he should
have included that clip because
it was really traumatic to her and it
was a private clip and stuff
but them trying to act with them trying
to charge him for posting revenge p
which is honestly a really horrible
thing to do and and seth
even says oh that's illegal blah blah
blah you should be in jail
you know in my opinion that's not
exactly what happened even though seth
was in the wrong in that
situation but you see people saying all
the time to discredit seth that he
posted revenge p
and i just find that charge to be like
just a ludicrous
character assassination by the entire
vlog squad
yeah and i feel like unlike the vlog
squad like i mean at least like
i mean we can acknowledge it you know
what i mean like when i because i kept
saying that too and i was just like
and again like you said not everyone's
perfect but it's just such a different
argument and also like again
he only used that now to defend david
rather than defending his friend aaron
who well why does he why doesn't he care
about the fact that david literally did
that to you actually even more
sometimes like multiple times and like
honestly like david did that to you
literally you asked not to post it and
he posted it of you
naked and i got harassed like so much
for that they're like oh my god you're
so disgusting and like david's vlog like
i guess like for being naked even though
he didn't show my nudity or something
like that i don't know if they talked
about in a podcast or anything i
remember for like weeks after people
were like
like literally people on the streets
were like would like tell me how
disgusting my like naked body was like
it was so gross like they were so
disgusting by your neck about like for
like probably more than it was yeah like
but like
legit people like that's great because
you didn't ask for it he surprised you
even though he was in your [ __ ]
bathroom listening to your headset i
asked him
david himself filmed it and uploaded it
and this was like the tan of stuff i
asked him not to
so it was like anyways scott's an idiot
because god has nothing to do with
anything you want to know what you want
to know what other conflict of interest
scott has
go ahead show the photo dan he has a
[ __ ] tattoo of david on his arm which
is
absolutely hideous by the way david 4
20. it sounds like a biblical verse the
way he's doing it
oh my god by the way is that the worst
tattoo you've ever seen in your life
and he's got the tongue out and
everything
satanic [ __ ] bro you said you told
yesterday it's like you have a tattoo a
day but i'm like no
i heard just someone read that in a
comment because corinna has a david
tattoo
um um uh this guy what's this scottie
has a
uh david tattoo so i was like whoa this
is like some next team show it should
also be noted that
todd and zane from the vlog squad
retweeted scott's video so like
basically
oh they did i didn't know that and i was
like you guys first of all they're the
other two dumb i thought they were the
dumbest vlog squad scott has now that
title because they're literally like a
box of rocks they have nothing to offer
oh so they all retweeted so they really
thought they were clapping back with
this oh i thought they i and even this
like reporter i talked to like this
person doing a story of this journalist
was like oh we thought the whole
narrative was gonna shift like you know
because when the vlog squad talks people
are like oh yeah now we see but like
it's just not the case and i'm
i'm just happy that people's like eyes
are opening up and especially when
pewdiepie said it he goes i always
thought this guy was doing like shady
[ __ ] yeah i thought that was interesting
too
because this is like someone who's not
really dramatic or unconfrontational and
he's talking about that things that
something's weird
you know i never going into this i
really had no problem with david
i just learned about the seth situation
i honestly didn't even want to talk to
seth i talked to big nick because he
reached out to me
and he said oh you should reach out to
my friend seth he was like
he was assaulted and i was like i've
heard about this seth thing i don't know
i was like people are over the david
thing and so i just brought seth on
because i figured you know what
let's just talk to him and then when i
learned about this i was like whoa
that interview blew my mind right yeah
and so now i've been going down this
whole david
dobrik hole with like the puzzle and
everything he did to seth and everything
he did to you
and now i'm like full-blown like if they
would have just responded and apologized
and said they don't do that stuff
anymore
but no no and that response i was like
this is gonna make everything so much
worse
he got a david got a new pr person right
when like
he's paying a pr person for this [ __ ]
she's the worst he's paying a pr person
for this [ __ ]
megan she's on the podcast all the time
she's not like if you have a pr person
and this was the recommended course of
action that girl needs to find a new job
yeah she's like a teeny she's like this
girl that she's like i mean 20. she has
like no experience
okay she's like okay my professional
opinion is victim shame and attack seth
and take no accountability no she
reviews it
okay so me and jason made a video after
oh that's crazy
and like like she literally was like and
so that's why jason ended up dumping me
because we made a video together kind of
explaining like whatever
and then she's like take it down take it
down her and natalie or whatever and
then like
jason's like i can never talk to you
again and then i went to the hospital
and jason you know did come to the
hospital and then david came too i never
made it again wait wait why
why were you upset that jason and dave
were there i never understood that at
the hospital
were they filming or something no david
david told jason like he couldn't talk
like when jason broke up with me that
that day he's like i can't talk to you
anymore like it's over it's done and
um basically basically david was like
the person behind it right and so i
didn't want to see him because i was
like what the [ __ ] is happening like i
didn't do anything wrong
because again i made a video once again
to reiterate before i
i got dumped like we were together i
made this video while we were together
because i was so pissed that was the
week of the tan of mojo clips
and i was so pissed i'm like i'm gonna
take any more like they can't keep doing
this to me on camera i'm gonna [ __ ]
fight back on camera because they keep
like
making me look like a complete idiot
whatever and so it all was from david so
when he showed up i'm like why the [ __ ]
is david here like i literally was like
spiraling because of him
i was so pissed so i told that's when i
screamed and ran off naked i'm like get
david the [ __ ] i was nuts i was like get
david the [ __ ] out
and all that stuff like that and david
did leave and jason say jason's like
bawling like crying at this point like
in cedar cyanide like in this back
because david came to the back like
hallway like i'm in the hallway on a
stretcher and david's back there with
jason i'm like what the [ __ ] oh you're
like i don't want to see your phone i
didn't even
see jason i think he i think he dm my
makeup artist or something because i
must have been texting i don't even know
what happened but like
so so david was there and i was so
[ __ ] pissed david was there because i
was like he was like the root of all
this like jason's like nothing you have
to apologize david like the law and i
was like i'm not politician for [ __ ]
because of the brandon kelvin because he
the underage girl
and so that's why i was pissed about the
david thing and so then when i saw him
but
for the record i was with david for like
a year and a half every single day like
thanksgiving all this stuff like that
like never once heard from him a
follow-up like he knew i went to a
mental hospital jason told him
i was up never once like are you okay
saw me in a hospital on a stretcher in
cedar side
like never followed up like he's the
worst guy ever so when he's like david's
like the nicest guy ever never fall out
doesn't have a mean bone in his body
i was like okay scotty i considered
david and i like really like everybody
has a mean bone in their body you know
what i mean what is he the superhuman
god
he doesn't have a mean boat he is a god
oh by the way he has an anger problem
he has a temper i totally believe that
yeah and by the way and by the way
scotty the most telling thing he said
was that when you when you do something
that upsets david he doesn't get mad at
you he gets disappointed like oh man
why'd you do that
i was like freaks how was that better
how is disappointment
better than anger you know what i mean
like that's such a manipulative way
and like cruelty way to deal with
somebody also why is david having this
place of
this place of high honor in your life
where disappointment means anything to
you like he's not your [ __ ] mom or
grandma and david
like david's like the youngest he was
like 19 when this started so these guys
were like 25
they're 30 now david's 24 and i'm like
what is with them it is like this weird
call
i think they're just so desperate
because they can't they literally can't
make it on their own they like have to
cling to this and i think they're just
like so desperate to save face or
as i like to say pick me i'm learning
all the gen z terms the pikmi boy
and i think he just wanted to like it's
like a call like if you can prove you
like
sacrificed yourself or push yourself
dude someone made such a good insightful
comment about the set situation
they said of course of course seth never
got the clout just like this guy jonah
and big nick it's because
people only get as much clout as david
wants them to because he portrays seth
and jonah and um and big nick
as the punching bags as the jokes and of
course they're not going to be respected
by the fan base so
of course they're never going to get
their own fans because people who do
follow them
probably don't respect them to begin
with because they're coming from david
so it's like
i thought that was such a good
insightful call that was that's the
narrative for
so long like and again i was like okay
with it because i think i like referred
myself as a [ __ ] all the time like so
many people that year
was like oh my god you're the [ __ ] from
davis vlog which is so weird cause i was
dating jason so i was not [ __ ] at all
i was like right you were
totally monogamous and that was like the
thing they portrayed
and they're like show us your tits like
people would do that for literally
so i totally get when seth was like i
don't want people or or big knicks and i
don't want people
harassing me on the street for being
short like that's just not the life i
want to live
yeah and again like it was just a funny
narrative because like i was on youtube
before them i was friends with shane i
was like oh
so like i was a different like and so
like that's the narrative he spun
because he had so much power and i'm so
thankful that people are like opening
their eyes like to this you know
here you wanna see what pewdiepie said i
thought it was really good
are people talking about this seems
hella
shady dude he's talking about his puzzle
i think
um i don't know david but i
he always get like i could be wrong but
my
my radar flicks up a bit i i kind of got
the same
feeling about him as i got a logan paul
when he was
not everyone hated logan paul
like don't get me wrong his videos are
really entertaining
but uh he always gave me that weird like
wait how does he
how is he able to get away with all this
[ __ ] like he's doing so much weird [ __ ]
like if i did that if i did that i'd be
cancer if i did that i could count
what the [ __ ] how is he doing it was a
magic song
are people pewdiepie is a great guy is
he a gamer
yeah he's a gamer that was his whole
legacy is that he was a gamer
the video he did about me was just like
commentary it was like how you do it he
was just like yeah he
he originally was a gamer and then he he
started diversifying his content do you
think he plays fortnite
why do you ask it's a tick tock
yep just touch down tomato town yeah but
what's that gonna do with pewdiepie
it's a game oh okay you think he's
playing he's probably played a game of
fortnite sure
i don't even know what fortnite is when
i want to play it just wiped out
it's it's kind of old it's not really
the end game right now but we're not
okay so
sorry i am i'm just saying you said you
want to play fortnite i was saying
there's just people don't play fortnite
anymore
can i get a galizzi please what's a
glizzy
a glizzy
[Laughter]
dad says don't give it to him he's
probably right don't give it to okay
okay wait just real quick just like i
don't even touch on it long because
they're like so
go ahead they're so irrelevant but like
all the barstool people have made videos
being like trisha paytas has tried to
cancel me
by the way did you guys see the video of
you guys laughing at me
i hate this i hate one okay also this is
like a misconception about me people are
like trish isn't drama with everyone
it's like
no i like call out [ __ ] for sure but
like barstool sports was like
i don't know all the random people
everyone besides dave porter like
everyone knows day porn and no one knows
the rest of them
but they all did these videos like
including dave portnoy on his podcast
whatever because he asked me to come
back they asked me to be on the sideline
never but
um but basically he's but basically they
tweeted me
like laughing at my porn but then they
were saying we did it at you oh they
tweeted the video
what and then they said then they said i
tried to cancel them i'm like i
responded to like a really mean tweet of
you guys like laughing yeah
sweet was so mean-spirited because there
was no there was just no
reason for it and then but then now
they're the whole narrative is like oh
trisha is like trying to like cancel me
and blah blah blah like we're allowed to
do whatever and it was gross
yeah whatever dave pork boy is a [ __ ]
idiot i got such a tool
anyways literally such a tool bro
i don't like that either okay whatever
so here's another interesting
insight cody koh is doing a podcast with
these guys josh and lucas
i don't know who they are but they were
talking about the seth pranks when it
happened a few years ago and these kids
were so insightful and they called it
prank he pulled on seth
they called it out for one yeah wow
these guys which one really it's
actually
the most insane [ __ ] i've ever seen it's
the most insane yes it's really
jason no uh david on his
buddy seth have you read it is that the
guy they make do stuff
uh no i don't think they make him jump
off of stuff and hurt him no no no
that's jonah i think i don't like how
they treat that guy
yeah i don't i haven't really watched
any of those ones i
the ones i've seen the ones i've seen
are the ones they make jason
make out with seth but seth doesn't know
that it's jason he thinks
it's like a girl yeah it's happened
twice okay and so
and every time i know every time like
jason will like take care of something
no he's not and so like jason will take
off his mask or whatever and he's like
what the [ __ ]
like like meet up with a dude wait wait
wait okay wait wait wait wait what the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] like wait they actually make it
that's [ __ ] cool
you know this girl she seemed really
intimate and uh and she came to me she
said hey let's go in the back room and i
and i was like yeah
awesome and we were waiting things were
getting hot and heavy
she turned off the lights you know and
she goes stick it in and
her voice was a little bit deeper but i
you know and
and jason turned around with my dick in
his ass and said what are you [ __ ]
gay
you got brains bro you got a prank
two years ago these kids wow and so i
was like wow people have been noticing
this [ __ ] for a long time that's amazing
because sometimes like
sometimes i get i get my head a little
bit i go is my just overreacting
you know what i know people are like
trish is better in my life but i don't
think so
anyway this is um josh
and lucas ovel i don't know who they are
but
but they're like young and the david
dobrik age range so like it's like good
that they're just
like i was i was like oh my god these
kids rule oh you know my prediction is
is
jason will be the next eliminator from
the group so you know how you'd think so
yeah scott was saying like
you know what when people go their own
way or they [ __ ] up and they do
something wrong we distance ourselves
from them jason's in way too deep
no but now because jason's getting like
he's he's at the heat of this right with
david of course but david he's going to
sacrifice jason
yeah he already is when you watch our
podcast like i used to listen to their
podcast and
jason was co-host now he's literally not
involved at all
they could just wheel his ass out and
people wouldn't notice it's just like
i think it's one of those things where
it's like you know i don't know i feel
like that would rock people too
hard they're slowly doing it the thing
is because it's no longer jason's
podcast it's david's talk show and
they're slowly doing i suck because it
happened with me
you they slowly do it so it's not
obvious like he's like a dying old horse
that you don't want to shoot because
it's a horse but at the same time
he's in misery we're going to turn his
ass to glue
it's expensive right see seaman's
expensive not glue we had this debate
before
the horse scene man makes the glue no
okay
no that's a different kind of glue but
he's just
that just needs to get off well i'm
wondering what is their next step going
to be are they just going to ignore keep
ignoring
i can't believe they okay this in this
situation they should have probably said
because
i was wondering if scotty was going to
erase the video and like because i feel
like scotty's getting so much [ __ ] now
that i
know what that feels like and it's just
horrible he's like posting a story like
normal everyone's just like posting and
david too everyone's just like posting
like nothing
like oh this is a video yeah it's crazy
you mean
yeah james charles is acting like
nothing he just posted a video and that
dude just literally just got outed for
being a pr
literal child predator literally he said
yes i sent nudes but he lied about his
age
literal child predator
like should this guy should be in jail
and he's still posting videos like
nothing and the overwhelming
reaction to the videos is like uh all
good
no problem here it just reminds me of
the woody allen [ __ ] that i'm watching
right
right you know there's no [ __ ]
accountability ah it's so
sad it's just so gross and then
meanwhile crystal dalia hides for like a
year and then he comes out
and also now he's like back in like like
getting in trouble or whatever it's just
like
it is a guy thing excuse me bless you
you keep saying it but it does suck i
feel bad for guys
i hate that listen i say that and i
don't mean to say that because i don't
want to
make it sound like female victims are
have it easier or something like
are they all female victims go through
the same exact thing as male victims all
this stuff
all this character assassination all
these fallacies we talked about victim
shaming victim blaming and stuff like
the same stuff they're doing to seth but
i i
i don't even want to keep harping on
that because i feel no but i'll tell you
what in that
in that same like on that same note like
david on the podcast and vlogs have
asked corinna and natalie both like how
much money to have sex with jason like
he'd be like i'll pay a hundred thousand
like no that's not enough
and he's like how much half a million
like no that's not enough so it's like
he's asked girls he's pa he said to
girls like i'll pay 300
to make out with jason and they say no
so they're saying that like with consent
right girls like saying no it's like
that you have to trick like a man in the
group to do it it's like and if it was
scott i guarantee you scott would have
knocked somebody out because god has an
anger problem and he like knocks people
out like he's always like biting people
there was a good vlog of david's where
like it was todd's fight and scott got
punched this is like the
equivalent of that like this is the
exact same thing where it's like not his
fight but he's getting like the knockout
which honestly he deserves it because
he's dumb like he's so stupid like
just everything about it oh scott's an
idiot so your music career has failed so
you don't
maybe you're better maybe that's why
you're coming for stuff come for me
scott
come for me i want to show you better
you signed a record label no one's heard
of it no one watched your last music
video
your clothing line failed he tried to be
a fan joy which was so stupid because
david dobrik has like
but he tried to be of android by making
people's merch failed
you know why because you never sent [ __ ]
i ordered from there i never got my
merch you never got the [ __ ] yours no
i don't even know what it was called it
was called some [ __ ] it was shitty
all your career things are shitty your
cbd oil is shitty that's not a new thing
you're starting
this investment on dispo doesn't look
like it's turning out in your favor
i'm not sure that this is the point
we're trying to make it's not a point i
just have a reason now i can go off on
scott because he's always been a piece
of [ __ ] too
like he was nice to me but piece of [ __ ]
in the background you know what i mean
i've seen him
like you know just be a piece of [ __ ]
overall he's just so condescending he
thinks he's so cool
the girlfriend you have now looks like
the girlfriend you had for four years
and you dumped her and then found this
girl right away they look identical
what'd you do interchange them okay all
right all right all right come on
it's not personal and his hair is
frosted tips you're like oh that's his
natural hair it's not it's frosted tips
it's frosted tips
mine's natural i'm like you suck okay
all right all right the cheshire cat's
not cute
who are you trying to appeal to children
okay all right all your girlfriends look
yeah
what's your thing that's not necessarily
the point how about check your friends
who dated 17 year olds not even brandon
okay watch this video so i don't know if
you
david scott okay oh my god i didn't
expect we talk about this so much i
don't care about it but whatever um
karina the girl she i guess replaced you
as like the
she was before me i think okay yeah so
she stayed she's stuck around i'm
getting nexium vibes from david because
what's an exam
it's this cult with david or kevin
what's his name anyway he was a cult
hbo did a whole documentary about it was
really interesting he would brand his
initials on people
oh so i'm getting so watch this clip of
corinna comes to him a long time ago and
says i need a couple hundred bucks she
was a waiter at the time
and david says i'll give you a couple
hundred bucks only if you tattoo
david's vlogs on your [ __ ] finger
where it's visible
forever decided that i
kind of broke right now so david said
he'd help me out and i'm gonna get a
tattoo on my finger
it's gonna say david's vlog he's paying
me a small lump sum of money too
200. what did i just do you just
promoted my brand for the next couple
years granny what are you gonna do now
with your new tattoo
are you gonna show off to other people
how stupid you are david like
dude i did this and now you're gonna
call me stupid yeah
so karina this is a perfect example
of people not wanting something in a
vlog and him paying them so karina this
is on vlogs do you know the story
of her giving like head to todd in the
back seat of the tesla right
david filmed it she goes you can't use
that she didn't know he was filming
shows you can't use that
so he didn't he's like the sucks like i
can't use it so anyways he had to like
she they
she i think it's like five hundred
thousand dollars he she's like he goes
how can i use this vlog she's like no i
don't want anything he goes how about if
i pay you like five hundred dollars
obviously she needed the money of the
time and she's like okay fine and like
didn't want it but you have to he
you have to like force someone to do
something it's not consent well you have
to like bribe someone to do something
well seth said the same thing he's like
i want you to
take those videos down and he says okay
how much to pay you
and then seth said that's when i knew
they weren't my friends
because he just wouldn't take the videos
down he wanted to pay him instead of
respecting
the fact that those clips made him
uncomfortable he's taking all these
clips down but he still thinks he did
nothing wrong by proving these texts
which absolutely proved not it's just
it's just crazy but
yeah it sucks um
so that's that pretty much well
good luck on dyspo peace and love i wish
you well
happy success i apologize one other
thing i wanted to talk to you about
before we move on actually two more did
we announce we were doing trivia
two more things i want to talk about
before we get to the trivia mm-hmm i
want to talk to you about beautiful
i feel like it's my parents beautiful
most amazing girlfriend ever
i'm giving the phone to my super hot
boyfriend
passing the phone to the only girl
besides my mom and sisters that i just
can't live without
i'm passing my phone out to my favorite
pop star noah's girlfriend also known as
charlie's sister
a person who is a really funny
girlfriend i'm passing the phone to
someone who deserves more
than a fake relationship for tick-tock
views
oh this is why
you're really really sad and you're
never gonna be happy according to your
music not my words don't come for me
i'm so crazy i can't watch myself i felt
i feel like you need to lay off a little
bit
first of all it's a joke it's it it
seemed really mean-spirited
they're like 20-year-olds it's you have
to give you
mean it just felt like i don't know
you're attacking the relationship and
just felt icky to me
because it's like they deserve look they
deserve love everybody deserves love you
think so i think that i think dixie like
has a lot to like be humbled about okay
fine
but like you don't need to attack their
relationships i'm not allowed to make
jokes on
it it didn't seem like a joke it just
seemed like mean spirit ugly [ __ ] like
no it just
it just seemed spirited that's all
coming from you
i'm do you may apologize i'm so sorry no
i'm just trying to give you friendly
it's fine i totally get it maybe it's
mean i'm trying to give you brotherly
advice
hilton i'm like a 30 year old old [ __ ]
on tick-tock making fun of you talkers
but hey
can we even make there's plenty of
critics valid criticism like i'm not
saying don't ever talk to them but i'm
just saying
maybe i can't call a relationship fake i
mean it totally is it's sad that these
people look up to this i don't want to
have
people i don't know if it's fake it's
100 fake
well how do you know i know well who
cares just let them have their fun
what's the big deal is this a tick tock
okay all right that's what you want to
tell me about yeah i just felt like it
was a little bit
i feel like it just
i mean if you're on the internet and
you're like the biggest i know i'm not
saying you can't
say it like no talk about people don't
make jokes about people no i'm just
concerned about you like that
like i just don't want you going on and
on about them it was like one tick tock
i made about dixie and noah like
relax like a tick tock i'm just looking
out for you
okay boomer yeah maybe i don't know what
that even means
are you a boomer no i'm not a boy i'm
not being gen z i'm
not even close to a boomer my parents
are boomers
um dixie's an idiot look i i'm not
disagreeing with you i'm just thinking
like
no she's for your idiot it just doesn't
i don't know don't dance at the end
where
are you making one of their matter
movies i just say and i know you have
beef with them
like i just say it doesn't necessarily
look great for your image to be
attacking their relationship i don't
think i'm really that concerned about my
image i think you're
more concerned about my image of me i
literally i don't give a [ __ ] like i
said i'm up and down
i'm just giving you listen i'm just here
okay fine
i'm just looking out for you i can be
canceled i'm fine honestly
according to vulture according to
vulture you can't be canceled okay
that was the yeah i mean eventually i
will be i'm sure
no i cancel myself when i'm dead that's
a cancellation
death that's the ultimate cancellation
anyway
that's that dixie's no no it's not just
that okay
dixie
oh so it is that so that is that what
because i said that's that you said that
isn't that and then you said never mind
so that is that
gabish also noah beck on the cover of
that magazine wearing high heels and
fishnets that's not like
edgy or funny or anything it's like it's
just it's it's why did he be like oh my
god toxic he's like he's not mass
like why is he the face of masculinity
why couldn't that you know what i mean
like just because he wore heels like
that doesn't make you like oh my god
he's so with it he's so open he's so
hey listen listen if they walk past me
on the street i'd spit on all of them
and the way that i look wait you can't
say that okay
me but you said you could spit on them
yeah let's put it up number eight okay
so let's put on each other abs please if
you [ __ ] spit on me i will freak out
today that i don't regardless of cover i
don't want you spitting on me
okay i like being you know there was
that clip of tana going around getting
spit around and honestly
if it wasn't covered kind of hot i like
spit
yeah but we're not and we're not engaged
in i'm engaged this is not the situation
we're spitting on someone would be
appropriate okay
talk to moses about that thank you wait
why
okay here there's one other thing
someone put together a compilation of
you saying
um wait what was i supposed to say to
that club should i apologize am i being
canceled for it i didn't even know that
no no no no no no you're not be canceled
you don't have to apologize you just
didn't appreciate it i
i just saw it and i was like i just i
just don't think that you
that it just looked like you i just
didn't think it was necessary that's
all oh okay thank you for that you're
welcome i will take it into
consideration
next time i hate dixie i know i know
i think she's very distasteful i think
she's dumb i think she needs to be
educated before she speaks
i think her parents need a lot of
looking after and stuff like that she's
just dumb
they still support james charles you
dumb prick i agree that's [ __ ]
predator you guys
i agree okay and also oh [ __ ] here we go
if you don't want to be paparazzi oh the
windows were down they wanted to be
paparazzi
we're just so sick don't go to catch and
saddle ranch if you don't want to be
paparazzi and the fact that you and noah
both say you still support james that
you guys love james he's a predator yeah
that's not okay he's a pr
he admitted to it he admitted to it like
what and you still support him
can i get a giz glizzy please i'm like
at an auction like a boza i'm at a white
trash auction you can't blizzy
you know who you can make fun of you can
make fun of predators and people who
support predators
and dixie emilio and noah beck had said
it un-catch on their little paparazzi
that they said
that they support james one glizzy
please i'm an anti-dixie demilio
no just as it is i'll take it as it is
thank you so much thank you thank you
keep going honestly she also thinks
she's a celebrity i was watching a
podcast where she thinks
she's not celebrity she's not a
celebrity i'm sorry you're just not
you're
not
dude you're right you're right
good point okay a-list should we go to
saturn
do you think people care about me yeah i
think you will get paparazzi no they ask
my favorite is when they asked dixie
charlie and noah about me
i don't i can't watch it because it's
like i think we should go there and see
if they care about it oh my god
i'm down that's my worst fear i don't
know what it is about like
these tick tockers but oh i probably
shouldn't say this but whatever i will
lair ray dm'd me do you know him he's
he's a frenemies fan now he said he's
been binge watching frenemies and he's
like wow did my
tweet really offended you i was just
trolling you or whatever he apologized
yeah i he seems like a nice guy from
american though and i said
hey bro don't hang out with predators
like the lopez brothers and james
charles
i did good for you yeah i agree you know
i said that other than other than the
fact that he's like best friends with
james charles
i said you're the company you keep bro
but also thank you for the damn ever i
nev whenever these
tickets a lot of tick tickers have been
signing my dms lately and i never know
if they're gonna troll me so i'm always
just like how can i help you because
they usually say hey that's like their
first thing but i'm like oh i'm so
curious i want to know
so i'm like how can i help you just so
like you know whatever and then i try
and gauge where they're at but he was
sending me voice memos so i feel like
they was like
legit i don't think he's you know what i
don't you know what i told him you wanna
watch this
compilation wear a mask you know because
and don't throw parties
that's the my critique on larae maybe
any other critiques for him that you
want them to know i think in general
yeah cool here's a video of you going um
for five minutes
see me in the street i will do video
shout outs for your friends whatever
don't ask me to go
because i don't do that anymore like
that was like the next moment no you
still do it definitely i literally hear
you do it every episode
and i just don't say anything because
it's like i don't want to beat the dead
horse but you literally mmm
everything not that people love it
it was a different time
[Music]
here listen up but i just love them it's
fast
in september you know what i mean
so you ruined it mm-hmm
if you guys are interested it's on km
sasaki's
channels i like the compilation oh i
just saw a clip beneath that can i just
say that nobody really cares about this
why can't i just say it
uh yeah what clip it's not a clip but i
i commented on amy's tick tock so did
you see everything's fine
oh yeah i saw it you made peace out
there was 77 comments below my comments
and everyone's like yay yeah i saw it
that was nice
no you're cute that wasn't big that was
big for you i have a little bit of a
temper so i think i go off in the moment
because i get really heated i think if i
let things simmer for a couple weeks
which i can never do
i think i would like not react so crazy
are you ready for jewish trivia
it's time he's a muslim right yes he is
well i don't think he's like he that's
his background yeah
you know what moses told me i can't wear
muslim scarves i wanted to wear one he
said don't
do you want to wear like a high job
hijab or whatever i like the way they
look
yeah oh yeah that's a whole lot that's a
lot i wouldn't do that no no but sure
there's a story about david and jason
like ripping off someone's hijab
have you seen that one yeah why was it
real
yeah and the girl like came forward to
me and stuff but it was also like on
video like in a vlog
yeah i guess they took it down look at i
i think it's on video that's not funny
at all that's so rude yeah she was like
i was like
mortified and jason did it jason ripped
it off i'm telling you jason give me
some snacks watch it
yeah i'm curious what's their next step
gonna be if they're just going to ignore
me i'm ready they're not suing anybody
oh my [ __ ] god
i know dude come at me you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm begging you please
you guys sue me please i'm begging you
i'm talking directly to david dobrik
jason
whoever's listening sue me please
with peace and [ __ ] love i love it
we're so like
i'm so unafraid of a lawsuit trust me
unlike the last guy and went into a
lawsuit i know your ass has the money to
pay for my legal fees
so trust me i asked them when i beat you
for a [ __ ] [ __ ] definition
lawsuit i will be coming back for fees
[ __ ] me too me if y'all got one million
from woody allen and legal fees so boom
episode last night it was she got one
million dollars in legal fees from him
oh i fell asleep during the last step
um sue me too you got me hyped as [ __ ]
sue me
sue me i want to show this proof i've
got these receipts i got more receipts
than i've even said because i didn't
want to look crazy but i got even more
receipts to me too
i hope if anyone does suing it's seth
suing david
and jason well yeah i mean that is like
such a like
people think that people are like
debating if they can i'm not saying
that he could be held criminally liable
but i am saying that seth
has a very strong case for a lawsuit
again of civil
damages against yeah david i mean
david's like admitted to it on audio
yeah it's like an easy [ __ ] slam dunk
after that podcast clip anyway you wanna
do juice trivia yeah and can i also say
i lost two pounds by eating
anything i wanted because i was only
look how skinny i am today can i show
people
yeah i feel very skinnier look wait
what are we doing okay i i
i actually i did kind of feel like she
looks thinner i don't know if it's
i don't know if it's the no this would
make me look fatter because it's like
clinging to me
but it's black you know jesus
okay eating whatever i want i had cake i
had ice cream
and i just went on the elliptical i know
we're not talking about weight because
like ew
why no wait you look great though
honestly you do look great and i'm so
happy you're not on keto when you
announce i was like oh i'm so happy
because like it's just not healthy for
you
mentally physically keto's dumb but this
week i'm i'm
i'm back on the weight loss there's like
low calories i feel like i can't talk
about it because people get so invested
in there
and then they go oh he didn't do it they
get so sad for me and then people go i
even saw one comment where he's like
ethan's so [ __ ] that he has no
willpower he can't even lose weight i
was like
well i feel the same way you know what i
mean that's how i feel dude trust me
yeah
trust me when i tell you that fat people
know they're fat we know we have an
eating problem you don't have to tell us
i hate when people like point that out
to me i'm like i get it
but also just trying to be a little
happy in life you know all right let's
do some jewish trivia
by that and not telling me there's this
is one of one dude
how was someone with one item uh one
question please
block your name in my comments on tick
tock not to bring them up but why'd you
do that
because on the fashion nova one
everyone's like tagging you and being
like and i was like
oh you did the fashion show you blocked
my whole name on your whole channel
just for that like that day you put it
back but yeah because i could not i was
like okay come on stop
well patricia fashion nova knows that i
[ __ ] hate them so
i love them okay that's fine and i hate
them here i'm gonna eat a glizzy you
can't block my name that's
that's that's outrageous
[Laughter]
oh my god how is it
i love it really do you feel ha i feel
like you're also just like
happier like you're not you know what i
mean like
you said you gained weight on keto or
you just didn't lose any
i think i gained two pounds actually
mm-hmm yeah
i mean it's not really good you know
that guy that like invented the keto
diet diet of like heart disease
of course i mean how could you not yeah
it's such a ridiculous diet can we play
the trivia please why am i sitting here
wait can we do the bungee thing too
those bungee ribbon things did you see
that on tick tock can we do that flying
bungees
can we do the trivia please what do we
win
that's a good question what do you want
is there a
some sort of bed on here um
um how about
i don't know what am i playing a [ __ ]
place
how many times do i have to ask all
right you guys have uh your little white
boards next to you
you're gonna need those okay
today all right
jewish trivia everybody all right
everybody this is the moment you've been
waiting for it
ready i gotta take like half the bread
off i love that we have so much tea in
this and you're gonna call it jewish
trivia
i'll probably add something else that is
no i didn't i didn't expect us to talk
so much about that
let's just call it like we like david
dobreck is a giant
d-bag no i'm just sure it's the ddd
david dobreck do you bag
ow okay all right we played a [ __ ]
driver
chewing into the mud seriously
oh my god good job
all right first question uh we'll start
out nice and easy
top top level uh basic knowledge here uh
who is said to be the first jew
the first jew the first jewish person oh
my god easy
really yeah
i'm just gonna take a guess because i'm
not really i'm not really good with the
biblical [ __ ]
i'm all about the biblical but i think i
know i don't know
ready all right let's see what you got
moses that's incorrect that's not true
abraham abraham is correct abraham moses
he freed the jews they were all
egyptians you just said that they
i thought they gave him the name jews
after he freed them weren't they
egyptians and they became
no the jews were slaves in egypt it's
all part of the whole it's the whole
story
uh abraham had the technical dream coat
the loser has to do something
i would say joseph don't make it up now
now you're like oh she's gonna lose
i something about mel gibson because
he's such an anti-semite like i know mel
gibson i used to go to his church in
malibu
yeah you have his number i used to
what yeah let's give him a ring right
now we have to lose us a prank call him
and say hey anthony semi
bye hey anti-semite bye okay whatever
next ethan's winning
did you love this game
all right second question well i guess
this one
this one you guys are going to know
because we just talked about abraham
oh my god what did he do he's got the
first jew didn't he like kill his son or
some [ __ ] or
well he was willing to kill his son and
then god stayed his hand
yeah the bible is such a uplifting
heartwarming story god goes
and you have to sacrifice your firstborn
son to me and kill him viciously
and he's like all right god whatever i
gotta do and god's like boom test you
[ __ ] that's only ultimate
no all the time new testament god is
where it's at so
really that's why you should be jews for
jesus because the new testament god's
really nice well
that's when god is harsh as [ __ ] yeah
well god don't play
god don't [ __ ] play again so abraham
is god bro
no all right this is what you guys
say god if you're a jew you're supposed
to be g dash d
no no god you could say god his real
name is yahweh what you're not supposed
to do oh my god don't say it
yeah well guess what i'm giving [ __ ]
stop
okay uh i'm already losing yeah who who
led
who led the jews out of egypt oh
take your time over there trisha now i'm
nervous making me worried the right
answer
okay just keep saying the same answer
for everything
the only jew i know
we know him we love him folks the king
well he wasn't the king but he was the
greatest prophet who never made it to
the promised land
because god scorned him after everything
he did for him moses
my moses sometimes referred to himself
he's like i was a pharaoh i was like no
you're not the moses he sometimes thinks
he's the moses well
oh moses was a pharaoh but he thinks
he's actually that moses are you do you
think you're moses moses
he thinks he's the og mode you're not
moses you're a modes it's not the most
he thinks he's the moses
sometimes sometimes he does think that
i'm like are you trolling me
he says no he sounds like yeah you so do
you're like
you're like babe i was a pharaoh i'm
like you're not a fan i think he's
kidding
you know pharaohs don't exist anymore
i'm holding out that he's still a prince
i think
he might be a prince of something like
dubai and so i'm still holding out that
he might be like really like
what does that mean for my wife too oh
right so maybe they both are aaron oh
wow could you imagine if she's like
princesses you're in the wrong [ __ ]
they don't honor they don't really honor
jews in dubai i don't think
that's why they're so special next
question please
all right we'll move off of the biblical
stuff for now
i was just warming up well we'll come
back to that but i i have a non-biblical
jewish question for you which one of the
following celebrities
is not jewish whoa which one is not
jewish ready
bob dylan oh harvey keitel
bruce springsteen winona ryder wait who
the [ __ ] is bob keitel can you show me a
photo
okay oh harvey tarantino reservoir dogs
can you show me a photo oh my god dust
on i could chill harbor kate is like
iconic
you can't see a photo why i i have a
right to know who he's referring to
he doesn't look at his nose
you don't have a big nose yeah i just
want to look at his big beautiful jewish
your nose is not big at all
okay thanks stereotype this guy pulp
fiction yeah i know
okay okay so run me those names one more
time okay the names are
bob dylan harvey keitel bruce
springsteen
winona ryder
interesting wow i'm torn okay
trisha you should know this wait oh
really
[Music]
i mean i know two for sure but i don't
know the other two um
okay okay okay
can i get a glizzy please out here no
more glossies for ethan
does he no glossies close you you're
being do not put the glitzy clipper down
can i get it close you back here please
no no i'm all right here we go here's
the answers reveal three two one go
uh trisha you gotta write bruce
springsteen bruce not jewish man
i thought but adam sandler's mother
thinks he is
oh that'll tell a line from this song
all of those people that i listen to
in the adam sandler uh oh man your
research is the hanukkah
katis not jewish but i love to put some
more inner
that's reason yeah what i got jewish on
me every night you know what i'm saying
inseminated with jewish
stop it's disgusting i hope i'm pregnant
anyways uh what is the holiest
accessible jewish site in israel
holy is what the holiest accessible
jewish site in israel holiest
the holiest
you were confident yeah you say this
confident all right here we go
three two one reveal the western wall is
correct what the [ __ ] did you write what
did you even write
jordan river that's where jesus was born
how does that not believe me
but not that's the wrong religion dude
and i don't even think that's right for
christians the holy sepulchre
in jerusalem well jerusalem is and
that's one of their holy sites it's
the number one tourist attraction that
the jews profit off of
no the holy sepulcher is huge no that's
where jesus ascended to
or he was reincarnated bro uh no it's
the same
it's the site of the crucifixion
reincarnation
right or right okay yeah yeah yeah the
resurrection is coming though i'm very
excited
that's hype get high you're coming
watch your ass jews oh my god what do
you think about that
all right the rapture are you scared the
rapture
i'm covering my basis yeah
jew and well the rapture and like
fundamental christianity
they love israel and israelis but the
root of their
their love for jews is is seated in
something very sinister which is
basically during the rapture all of
israel
and israelis will be annihilated so i'm
not a fan of the rapture
nor christians who subscribe to that
well wait
i don't know yeah
that's what i but then we're all
annihilated right but i thought it was
just because the prophecy says that
there must
be jews in israel for the rapture to
occur
and it's one of like the prerequisites
or whatever yeah and then we're
annihilated oh i guess that's true but
the good news is
you're not going to hell because jews
don't believe in hell christians believe
it
christians believe that jews will be
annihilated and go to hell for eternity
that's why i'm both a christian and a
jew because i don't believe in hell you
gotta pick sides girl you cannot sit on
the fence on this one
you're no i don't believe you're not
gonna go to hell during the rapture
jesus can be like you [ __ ] ride for
me or not
jesus looks you in the eye dead ass and
says you ride for me
or not yeah but jesus loves jews
he was one yeah he loves jews enough to
send the [ __ ] hell for all eternity
you don't go to hell he's like yo you
didn't suck me and you didn't accept me
in your heart
sorry technicality burning hell forever
no that's new testament
oh yeah burning hell for eternity you
literally just said jews don't believe
in health that's the old testament
god jesus is [ __ ] hellfire jesus the
hellfire guy
dope ah who's winning
obviously me ethan's winning by one
point two what the [ __ ] you call crack
i'm up by two yeah you didn't get but i
got bob dylan and bruce springsteen
oh right my bad why don't you apologize
i'm like david dobrik say i'm sorry
i just said my bad that's not saying
you're sorry i'm sorry ian
okay uh here i'll throw here's another
pop culture
more related one um what country
is the famous musical jewish musical
fiddler on the roof set in
oh my goodness oh countries then
yeah like where does it take place the
story huh
oh my god you know what
it's one of the songs from children on
the road do you know if it's on the roof
i know it i don't really know so i'm
just gonna have to take a guess because
i'm not all [ __ ] broadway like this
girl over here
it's about being jewish yeah there's a
lot of [ __ ] countries where jews live
was this
was it before or after the war the war
can't answer it
why the [ __ ] i i i deserve to have
what in what era of human history do you
think that there were fiddlers on roofs
damn i called you babe i call everyone
babe babe
what does that mean i mean look the war
is in the 40s it could be before or
after
oh my god when the [ __ ] have you ever
seen a fiddler on the roof dan what kind
of clue is that
yeah when have you ever seen one it's
fictious before the war
did you land okay what's the song that
they sing
no my mom's getting lame okay i'm just
gonna if i were a rich man uh yeah but
there's like a jewish song they sing in
there
i've written an answer all right here we
go here's the answer and
israel germany wrong on both counties
what takes place in russia
i was gonna write russia no
i was going to write russia girl i
literally you were literally making fun
of me people jews didn't really live in
israel before the war
my pronouns are they okay
my family's russian jews so you can take
it from hey
damn i was going to say russia yeah they
got they're not you know legit legit
all right i didn't know anyway so i'm
not getting that i thought for sure
israel
rhys riley that's funny you're getting
okay so i'm still up by one
yeah i guess the score hasn't changed
because neither of you got a point there
all right
here we go okay which of the following
words
is not yiddish ah
the official language that's a made-up
language and no one speaks anymore all
languages are made up dude hebrew
okay stop yeah where do you think
yiddish what country are you going to do
is like the original jewish language
hebrew was just invented like 50 years
ago
so they could communicate with you what
the [ __ ] are you to tell me about
yiddish
excuse me take a backseat girl you're
running over
you still might be able to figure it out
because yiddish words are very distinct
so ready which one of these is not
yiddish
bagel spatula schlock
or glitch what the [ __ ]
say it again hutzba
bagel spatula
all of those but one are you a fake
language
the jews did not speak yiddish you are
so
[ __ ] full of [ __ ] you literally don't
know what the [ __ ] you're
it's the official language of israel and
you know who smoked yiddish all the
[ __ ] jews before they were mass
murdered in germany
i do feel sorry for them that is sad
that that was a sad incident and then
imagine you sitting here telling telling
they're ghosts you're right their
language doesn't
okay let me ask you another apology noah
go ahead dixie and the jews
that you're gonna pump the jews in with
noah and dixie you you do they not
deserve the same amount of respect
you deserve each one an individual
apology noah is a
jewish word so he might be jewish kind
of like an overlap hey noah's ark
dixie not biblical god this is hard
can you just guess did you write one
already yeah
we gotta put a time limit on this one i
mean
whichever one sounds the least yiddish
to you
yeah i just got it's like multiple
choices that's your hint i i mean
how else can i give you a hint
all right ready this is so hard i feel
like this is a trick question
all right three two one reveal choice
glitch
spatula is correct spatula is not
yiddish oh my god
i got it wrong well i got it right
whatever they all have a chick in it
glizzy please
i finished them all can you make some
more glizzies
oh my god
all right uh moving on here uh
this is a relatively easy one what food
is traditionally eaten in israel
for hanukkah oh my god
oh my god these are so easy make them
harder
you haven't got one right like three wow
this those were
trick questions because yiddish is not
real okay ready all right three two one
reveal
jelly donut jelly filled doughnut also
known as sufgoniot in
whatever i know yiddish i know shiksa
you know you are shiksa people used to
call me that for real and i was like
like parents i'm like are you what are
you in the 1940s are you in the
holocaust right now why are you oh my
god
no offense though i don't mean any
disrespect to the holocaust survivors
or people who died in the holocaust the
victims it's sad too
i'll watch hillary's list again i
promise yeah give it another shot
movie night when we have dinner with
your mom we all oh that'd be fun that'd
be fun
it's a nice light viewing all right uh
score please
yep thank you very much wait that's a
brilliant
more than two i got jelly donuts i got
bruce springsteen i got moses
i got that's what were the other
questions like you forgot i'm sure i
think she has three yeah i think she has
three
yeah why is it so hot every time i do a
game i don't know i just don't know why
it's so hard to keep track
i don't trust you guys as score keeper
i'm not keeping the score i'm not no i
know but you've messed up he was messed
up it's just
oh you've messed up before moses with
pizzas and love not this guy but before
it's just not it's like come on you guys
this is the integrity of this game is
everything
if we can't touch the score what can we
trust
can you imagine if the moses [ __ ] up
when he was like trying to free the
slaves and he's like [ __ ] the ocean just
drownded them all
that'd be god's fault that'd be moses's
fault for thinking a good part of c
well god well they only went in it once
it parted you know i mean if god was
like psych and then drop the c on him
that'd be good
that's on god that one's on
all right here we go all right so so
it's five three i believe five three
okay
all right so at what ages do bar
and bot mitzvah usually take place oh my
god
oh i got offered to play obama so did i
tell you this someone offered me ten
thousand dollars to come to there
um i guess to perform are you gonna do
it should i is it in l.a michigan
i guess traveling maybe not i wouldn't
travel for it but if it's an ally maybe
if it was in l.a i'd do it
you would no no no i wouldn't but maybe
you should we should do a duo okay
we could sing i don't do bar i don't do
where mitzvahs
[Music]
neither of you gave a complete answer um
but
i said bar and bot
well then you just gave away that you
don't know the answer i guess it's 13.
it's 30. it's 13 for bar
it's different for women well women it
doesn't even count we both get a point
now it's a bat mitzvah we only know a
bar mitzvah here
well women what happened to women
empowerment not in the jewish world it
is international women's day today
oh congrats that's exciting
that's so cool all right we both get a
point i can't believe i mean
in america everyone gets mitzvahed at
13.
it's it's 12 for women am i am i hebrew
school everyone got it got it at 30.
it was reformed i just said 12 and 13.
so i should get you wrote 13. but
it doesn't really matter you guys gave
the same answer so the score doesn't
actually move at all you know
doesn't matter go ahead go ahead that's
not what he said
you're really coming for me today oh my
god well you're stepping you're stepping
to me on my turf
talking mad [ __ ] oh my god i'm
jealous because i'm getting married in
israel i was married in israel
so why would i be judged where are you
yeah okay can't argue next i don't know
what's back
i was literally married in israel really
yes
oh congrats thank you that's dope yeah
okay
all right i mean what i did start this
episode by talking off how i had to get
a letter from a rabbi
to get married in israel right we just
had the conversation that was literally
this episode
i was literally thinking i should pee i
remember this coming for you
i remember it now that you said i
remember good job i'm glad you were
listening
you look cool you look dope you always
like dope did you see all the tic tacs
saying how like oh why am i attracted to
ethan in this outfit
i did see a couple do you find like a
compliment or insulting that people i
think people are just goofing around
no i think no you did actually look you
look pretty good yeah you did a little
thing
but is that an insult because they're
like why do i find him attractive no
you like it you'll take it no i i'm not
use dude the past
like what since i've been like fat
which is like the past five years i
don't i don't expect anyone to be
attracted to me so no i don't take any
insults you're literally not valid stop
saying you're fat cause you're
definitely not well i'm not like attract
i'm not i'm like
unattractively chubby you're
attractively chubby i would say
oh well thank you a lot of people can't
pull off being chubby i think i pull off
being chubby too well i don't have a
choice i'm chubby so whether i pull it
off or not we're more of the attracted
chubby people we're like the
top echelon of chubby oh thanks chubby
cute
chubby cuties are we chubby cuties
that's cute
i like that that's awesome can you make
sure you make a double xl in our front
of me setting
of course we'll do up to 3xl dope yeah
cool i'm a double xl kind of girl
all right yeah well of course we'll do
that here we go the name
the three largest ethnic groups of jews
in israel largest what ethnic groups
what is ethnic what does that mean
specifically like colors of skin
what's that like like define countries
i don't know how to more define ethnic
group than
because like ethnic could be
like the difference between oh you're
meaning like those hard complicated
words
the yes yes the hard part oh my god
there's three uh uh sort of the three
biggest ones
wait three you said two no i said three
and if i said two i meant to say three
he said three yeah that one threw me off
because i was like i knew there was two
and then i was like wait wait what the
[ __ ] you said two
three but there's only two bro
there's two major ones there's you're
literally wrong right now dan oh my god
even moses is like i don't know what
you're talking about do you know the
third one
oh maybe i maybe i do know yeah exactly
right so maybe that is it
oh no but that's the
dude you're wrong yeah bro you're
[ __ ] wrong
okay too i got it i got it i got it
jesus some questions we got here
okay you ready i think i only got one i
don't i mean
dan i hate stepping to an israeli but i
just looked it up it's not the same he's
not an expert on jewelry dan you don't
know what you're talking about i'm
looking at it's sephardic and eshkenazi
yeah
there's only two what's the other one's
the third one it's mizrahi
yeah yeah it means rocky just means
middle eastern bro it literally means
middle eastern
yeah okay
what did you write eugene lovey about
that but i didn't see what you wrote i
mean i'm reading
dan you're wrong i'm telling you you
guys are gonna get slammed in the
comments because i'm literally
fact-checking
right now he literally means middle
eastern how dare you
okay how dare you like get discredit
them
misraheez i don't think anyone in israel
would consider themselves rocky right
yeah yeah yeah
and safar dim are sometimes used
interchangeably although they mean
separate despora groups the safari jews
community were formed
i am telling you the way the words used
i've lived there for five years
i know because you love to cheat no but
he's oh my god you're wrong
okay man i mean it's a technicality
that's not used in common parliament
which one are you i'm uh ashkenazi i'm
mizrahi
you're oh you're mocking oh for real
i told you this a million times i was
thinking about peeing
wait how much moroccan are you well my
first test was 18 but i took another
test i'm like 23
i swear moroccan yeah i swear you look
like you have a little ethnic in you
people always said that and i was like
that's crazy that's what and then i'm
like oh my god those husbands like i am
like which side of your family
my dad's side so is your dad like 50
then i was like he was like hungarian
greek like mediterranean
that means he must be 50 if you're 20
yeah
25 percent but he never did so that
means one of his parents is straight up
moroccan it doesn't make sense how do
you not know that
well because well i didn't know my
grandparents on his side they both died
young and so so
i didn't know and so i was just thought
we were like greek because i was kind of
like not
stereotyping but i was always kind of
like hairy so i always just thought like
oh maybe it's my green side
when i was a kid i just had like facial
hair and people would like make fun of
me for i was like 12 with like a
mustache i was so sad can we get a
gallizzy please i wax
no glizzlies
no that was no point for trisha uh ian
if i have to [ __ ] spell it out bonus
point name a jew in hollywood that's
both ashkenazi and sephoratic
no eugene lovey okay nailed it got the
bonus point that's one for me zero for
trisha what's the score
that's what i'm talking about when is
the teddy fresh and jew collab coming
the juke lab do i need the license is
that from
seriously can you do a star david merch
that's everything with the with the
teddy bear with a little star of david
on it
i'm not into the whole i'm not really
into that but then you could wear
something so people don't have to wear a
tele instead of that we could wear like
a little teddy fresh jew bear
you guys got both you and you it's great
yeah i'm not
sure donate to the jewish organization
i just don't like including all that i
love a star david it's proud you know
why i wear the star of david because in
the holocaust
they put the star of david on people to
identify them as jewish and like oh
these are bad people
now we wear proudly because we're proud
to be jews right i think they wore
proudly before the holocaust too no babe
wasn't it a thing like
put this on them their disgrace oh i
know that happened in all cause but
people wore star davis before the hulk
well now we can wear this and not get
killed right so wear it proud
we're proud but you're not a jew you
wouldn't be in a holocaust
you wouldn't be in a concentration camp
where would i be
i don't know okay not there that's cool
i would i wouldn't care i would
sacrifice myself if i could go in place
of my
fiance i would go in front of him really
well so nice of you to say now
there's no risk here i so would i would
hide him that'd be the person i'd be i'd
hide him in my house
well i guess we'd be married so he's not
hidden we'd be on social media they'd be
like we see him
i wonder if the wife of a jew of a yeah
i don't know that there was much
intermingling back then i don't think
jews married
non-jews was it really that bad like it
was like almost like interracial like
back then right like it was like
i think there were no i mean i think the
jews just really kept to them they just
married with him they still are like
that you crazy being like we only want a
marriage
yeah okay calm down yeah it is still
like that but back then it was even more
as you can imagine next question please
thank you so much
i want people to know i like i really
love them from like a place in my like
gut like i love them so much
or heart gut i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're
you kind of i just love jewish culture i
just wish i had a culture i really don't
have an identity of my
own that's why i'm like trying to be so
many different identities because i
don't know who i am
you're moroccan apparently it's crazy
what do you you don't what you're the
background of your family
i don't know my mom doesn't know hers at
all but like we do have greek in us and
we do have hungarian and stuff like that
we have like that stuff but i always
just thought i was like
why not the moroccans have rich culture
yeah maybe i shouldn't i don't know
their food is bomb
i love moroccan so good maybe i should
cook that yeah people want us to have a
cookoff because people are saying i'm a
better cook than you now
because i've been cooking i would love
to have a cookoff we should definitely
do that i saw yeah people want that
maybe next week
thank you binging with baptist she i
learned recipes from him all right next
question we get babash on the show
um yep actually that one is gettable i
don't
know
why not i mean it's just babish do you
know him right yeah baby
with babish oh yeah what is it they've
been with baby no it's on baby
basics with babish or babiness culinary
university or something
bibing bibing with babish he taught me
how to make a great decimal
for my mac and cheese and it's amazing
okay dan
all right thank you so much what is the
name
what is the name for the practice of
jewish esotericism that in recent
decades has been
co-opted by many western celebrities
such as madonna
ashton kutcher and ariana grande
okay ariana this is a weird one you got
it
easy kabbalah kebab both got it that's
the point
yeah that that [ __ ] is weird the whole
kabbalah thing it's you're part of your
culture
the cabal thing is like a weird-ass sect
of judaism right it's like kind of just
odd dudes doing weird [ __ ]
it's just mysticism we should get some
red strings to wear on our wrist
also were you teased as a jew growing up
or no not really no ventures like
whatever
yeah there was lots of jews nobody gave
me any trouble yeah we never we never
knew that as like a thing but i went to
college and i met like some
uh foreign exchange students from europe
and they're like i have never met a jew
in my whole life and i was like really
she's like i did not expect that you
would be like this i was like what
so same i never met a jew until i moved
to l.a yeah so that's super weird but
but i think that's why the jews live in
l.a and new york
right it's weird if you're not jewish
yeah it's a little dicey it's weird if
you're not jewish exactly
okay god dan all right um this one is
sort of a
uh name as many as you can style
questions
uh list as many of the ten plagues of
egypt oh my goodness as you can
what the ten plagues from the story of
moses
okay
i think i got five like legit five
all right are we good i think so
let's see what we got okay ready mm-hmm
how many have all right well
let me read them off okay all right i
guess do one of them at a time why don't
you read the ten
and then let's see and you guys can see
if you got them right right water
turned to blood oh and frogs
i got frogs okay so it rained frogs
lice slash gnats damn it didn't get that
one
trish are you confused did you miss the
point
oh you're doing the ten commandments
aren't you oh the commandment is not a
plague for the record
he said moses brought it down he didn't
say anything about moses
about moses oh i did he said that he
said yeah he died
yeah and this is part of the story of
moses yes he brought these plagues to
egypt to egypt because he they would not
release
the jews this was the punishment for the
egypt ten plagues
so i've got frogs well clearly you got
zero yeah i think ethan's got this one
no that's not fair i thought it was the
play um
the commandments yeah you said the
plagues what do you want i mean what do
you i mean what can we do okay so you're
just going around discovering 10.
you know the plagues i know 10 plagues i
know
do you know any of the plagues would you
have got this right yeah
no you wouldn't yeah the frogs raining
lotus death of first born disease boils
bad breath
bad dick and sloppy wipes i would have
beaten you i know more
well maybe you should listen well that's
unfortunate because yeah one more for
the like
there's a reason people call me king of
all jews i think that's howard stern
i think it's jesus oh right he's king of
jesus he's the king but i'm i'm here to
dispute that title
all right i'll give it to you really
think of jews no not the game but the
king of jews oh thank you i want to be
the
mother of jews the mother of all jews
yeah that's a pretty
ambitious title but i think there's a
shot really
i think there's a shot you could
recognize for that thank you go ahead
dan
all right uh just a few more here we go
for the record because i knew those
during rosh hashanah when do you eat
apples dipped in honey when yeah when
or why because i know why when even
moses is like sorry
during rosh hashanah but when in the
ceremony
oh my god there's a whole ceremony bro
you get these
who wrote this who wrote this um tell me
who wrote this
i don't know i think this just came from
a jewish trivia
yeah i think a why is probably better
when in the ceremony yeah
right before the celery and the second
before the parsley so you're saying you
don't know the answer
well you eat it with everything the
pomegranate the fish head like you kind
of just have it
when do you do it during the seder you
eat it after the challah
on the first night sorry i made some
bomb ass holla yeah what
no there's two nights there's the
beginning and end yeah
this is a very this is a contentious
question let's throw this one out all
right skip
yeah i love that part of it though i
love the apples
slams every time it slaps the [ __ ] out
of
we had rasher shannon together last year
that was when the beginning of the end
where my family hated me
right right to be yeah we'll do another
one
you guys know what you guys know why it
went so poorly
you you didn't eat the apples dipped in
honey after that
we'll do another one we'll do another
one oh cause because your guys mom is
coming hopefully
and we're gonna have a slap and banging
[ __ ] holiday when she's
her cooking is like off the rails bro
i'm so i'm so nervous i'm so excited
yeah
no they're mom's gracious can i say the
prayers you think of course what
there's no there's no rules under this
house okay cool not that i'm so excited
all right uh it's gonna be so much yeah
it's gonna be great good just a few more
questions
what is the name of the jewish
circumcision ceremony
you know what yeah surprise bris briss
oh good for you they both got it do you
know how many days after birth
well of course you do you just had a
baby do you know what you didn't finish
your question how many days after birth
that it's performed oh well i didn't
mind that like the day after
no i'm not supposed to do you're
supposed to give it a week seven days
yeah eight days
huh i almost included that question i
was like there's no way trisha would
know that ah you think i'm an expert i'm
about to have a jewish baby we need to
know when to get the rabbit
in here i recommend doing it at the
hospital for real we're gonna have a
water birth at home so probably not
okay you guys if that's what you want to
do
well
let's do one more question you want a
water of course you do
both did you want a water birth of
course you do
oh my god you better have a dog you can
have a doctor on standby
okay good okay it's not a troll like he
really loves water and i'm like
maggie you should take her to the
hospital bro oh coven
oh you can do a water birth if it's in a
hospital we have a big ass pool babe we
can just do it there
oh yeah it's gonna be nice go swimming
afterwards take a dip
he wants a water baby cool down
yeah do it if you do the hospital that's
a fun way to have a baby
okay but but regardless it doesn't
affect the outcome of the circumcision
right i would have a doctor do it yeah
rabbis [ __ ] don't know what they're
doing you wanna do it
um and uh where did you extrapolate that
no okay the rabbits like suck off the
baby
you can watch them do it obviously so
they don't do that
but they're just not trained
professionals like a lot of times
they'll mangle the kid's dick
okay okay i would just let like maybe
we'll just have girls at the hospital
they're really they know you're an
advocate for the hospital i i respect
what you say okay whatever i respect it
i just said you'll have a hospital water
birth
cool we're down okay good all right last
question here we go
what is the name of the mixture of
fruits nuts and wine
served at passover what is what
the little mixture of fruit nuts and
wine served at passover
fruits whoever wins this wins everything
no what are you talking about i'm
wearing it yeah i'm trivial like whoever
usually it's a close game right now i'm
up for like five points
yeah fruits nuts and wine at passover
i know this one what is it what say it
again the terminology what's it
do you know what this is
okay can you just say that it's the term
you're looking for right a term
hello yeah it's just yeah there's a term
fruits
nuts and wine
bro what i'm confused on this one okay
i don't think i'm right but i wrote down
what i got all right let's see it
sacrifices uh no i g it's called uh
harold seth hollow well you're on crack
with these questions
oh i love that you're picking up trish
terminology and you're on crack
you didn't invent your own crack i think
i've been saying you're on crack to
everybody for like at least five years
now
okay i'll i'll give you a question i do
peace and love all the time i still say
no i like i mean you're on crack i like
that i'll give you credit for that
i wonder if i can put if i can stamp
glizzy gripper on the
hot dog no so what's the final score
here uh do you want to do one more
can we do one for all the marbles like
for a winner that's no
i'm out of good questions okay we're
getting really annoyed by all these
questions
that question doesn't make any uh hey
look at me i
appreciate it you literally just google
it it's and i was right about that other
one too
you're gonna see everybody [ __ ]
you get so mad over nothing it's
literally jewish trivia that means
nothing i mean to the jews it means
something but us it's like we're in
front of me
you know what i'm not angry how [ __ ]
dare you get so angry
you're like no that's [ __ ] it's like
it says it online it's obviously
something you don't know
literally you don't know i've lived it
you all don't know [ __ ]
god [ __ ] both of you i win this show is
over
wow and moses agrees with me by the way
he's not the end of be all just cause
he's from israel doesn't mean well what
the hell do you know
and what do you see now he's looking it
up
look at me to the life i've been in the
trenches moses has been under the
treasure he's served in the army
you have not been in the trenches i've
been in the trenches
the metaphorical yeah yeah the
proverbial trenches
okay all right we're coming up on two
hours you should really wrap it up so
give me the final uh
tally here ian
that's bad for a boy not bad for a boy
a koi i would non jew i'm a they
is a [ __ ] girl no it's it's just it's
just uh
oh oh oh my god derogatory is it
derogatory
yeah a little bit yeah i'm okay i don't
i mean
i'm pretty sure she kind of said it in
the direction like oh look at that great
gray over there
yeah that's me too people said that to
be me well you are a boy
well you're and clearly based on you
know the
the scope final score you're going to
get the first time you actually
girl you are a boy
you are a jew
well that sounds racist you call me a
boy i can't call you a jew
jew is a tricky word because it both
means it is the right word but it's also
an insulting word you are a jewish is
that better that's grammatically
incorrect
we'll figure out how to how to talk you
crazy
yeah i prefer jew crazy okay that was
fun yay
i'm not really angry i'm just having fun
you actually won like legitimately one
without
cheating so congrats is that the other
one what about the science one i
i don't know what it was science oh the
original trivia one
from from orthodox to uh nazi
oh my god i love that do you remember
springtime for hitler
remember we gotta go um i am not
actually angry i just want to make that
clear i'm just having a good time out
here
have been trying to be entertaining and
then you coming in with your [ __ ]
you look like kiefer southerland right
now i love it lost boys keeper stethorne
oh yeah the vampire yeah you look dope
did he come on our show
for sure i love you he's so easy to get
yeah i think so
are he nobody's done [ __ ] since 24 right
nobody's asking for him but he was
everything on 24.
yeah that was a while ago though he's
not a jew we have to we have 24 hours to
put the bomb
there's a muhammad there's a jihadist
tried to nuke new york city
every plot every [ __ ] yeah such a
stupid show so dumb
so dumb we have to figure out how to
defuse this bomb in new york city we
have 24 hours
beep beep beep i didn't like it
also he's not like an action star he's
like kind of like a
he gives me like chuck norris vibes you
know what i mean like he's such a b-rate
actor oh
sure no that's like a compliment is kind
of iconic on his on to himself you know
what i mean he was but then when he was
like walker texas ranger vibes
no he was teaching people like not to do
[ __ ] keeper sutherland became the voice
of
uh solid snake from metal gear solid for
real
i was curious what he's done since 24
and that's like one of the only
notebooks we'll get him
so there you go yeah we'll get him
i feel like you're never gonna get a
guess that i want i feel like you're
literally just saying this every time
how many guests have we had on the show
dr drew now he wasn't a guest he was
more like a
yeah he was more like a i don't want to
guess until we get adam sandler as the
first one
and then we can get after that yeah
we're working on that all right
well guys it's been a fun wild ride
we've
said it all we've done it all we've
talked about david dobrik we're talking
about james charles we've talked about
moses himself the prophet the great
prophet of judaism val kilmer voiced
moses and prince of egypt not a jew
voicing moses how ironic but thank you
mazel tov today
[Music]
thank you daddy thank you daddy
all right guys we'll see you next week
for another episode of frenemies thank
you for joining us you know what time it
is
and um shalom
shalom shabbat much
bye
[Music]
so
you